So, I'll lay out my thoughts on this caller gate stuff and then
we'll we'll go through it. We'll see if we can find anything
in that bod. Okay. But Hassan says, "Okay, Ka didn't even have
that collar with the rumble thing on it or or the shock collar
on during the stream." Didn't even have that collar on.
So now he's giving you something tangible that if you could go
show that Kaio was wearing that collar that day, well, like it's
it's over. Like he's just lying about everything, right? >> Third
group of people are the ones who are like, "Look at this clip.
Look at that clip. Look at this clip. Like, it's obvious he's
moving his arms around. Like, he's he's
constantly in a state of of of zapping. And um they've moved
away from the initial
uh conversation, which was they moved away from the initial conversation,
which was that like she didn't even have that collar on to begin
with. And the only reason why I showed the collar was because
people were clipping other
Oh, so the argument is well people clip the other stuff and he's
showing what that caller is with the beeping thing on it. Okay,
>> first of all, are any of the cars legal? No. Even in
the maximalist position, even if like >> even if
what uh what like the the people that they're claiming are just
like a significant threat or whatever, like most I I've said
this already, e-collars that have shocking components
that feel like a TENS machine, which I've used on myself in the
past cuz, you know, I'm around dogs that have been uh trained
with that and use it.
um is is not not only is it not illegal, but it's also straight
up uh used in the uh e fencing for people and it's used in the
training of like uh dogs in general. >> E fencing for dogs,
I think probably not for people. So he says even in the that's
kind of what my position's been the whole time. Like obviously
there's
now here here's what we shouldn't misunderstand. If if my my
position is even if Hassan shocked the dog, he's still a good
dog parent. Now, if he shocked the dog and went through this
whole thing lying and carrying on a lie and trying to like continuously
prove that he didn't do it after the fact, that's sort of a different
kind of issue, a different kind of pathology that I would judge
quite harshly, but is not related to him being a good dog parent,
right? Good dog trainer. So, even if he were if if he were to
have shocked the dog, I I'm like, "Well, that's weird." But it's
just not related to the It's not related to the dog. I don't
think there's any reason to be concerned about his dog's well-being.
I think he takes very good care of his
Why does he keep lying so badly? Well, here's the thing, Time
for Pigs. If he's just lying and the the dog obviously is the
collar on that day,
then all you have to do is go through that VOD and find where
where the dog's wearing that collar where there's a picture of
the dog wearing that collar and it's obvious and show that, right?
Then then Color Gate ends. Hassan has proven a liar. He's giving
you something you can prove. And to me, I I find it a little
strange
that out of all the people following this, did nobody catch that
if you if you now show that this dog is there. So, is there definitive
evidence? Now, I'm telling you, revoked that basically in that
VOD, there almost certainly should be definitive evidence. We
should have some angle of Ka in those VODs that tells us whether
or not
there she's wearing the shot collar, right?
So, XQC, watch this clip.
And XQC, let's see. the XTC's reaction cuz I I do want to see
it real quick. This from yesterday as well. >> So, he's
looking for this. So, he's he was originally looking at the Hassan
saying that it's not the shock collar and then he looks at this
and he says, "Oh, that sure looks like it to me, I >> Right
there.
So, he says it's right there. You literally can't see it, right?
So, for the collar that that does actually have the shock component,
the shock component is here. It wouldn't be here. This is just
the buckle that you can see visibly in both.
So you you cannot see the shock component at all in the clip
where XQC talks about it, right? XQC is just full of here. This
is just totally incorrect.
Another classic XQC miss. Okay, just totally missed again. Very
unlucky. Trained with that and of zapping and which was they
moved away from the initial conversation.
>> No, it's hidden below by your fur. Okay, but somewhere
in that bot, you should be able to find
you should be able to find something, right? you should be able
to find it. And he's given you something tangible that you can
go and find and prove as in this entire time it's been like uh
like basically circumstantial evidence, right? You should have
like bulletproof evidence now. You can go through that VOD, you
can figure out if you can find the the actual e-collar part and
it's over, right? It's just over at that >> She didn't
even have that collar on to begin with.
>> She didn't even have that
then. What the is it wearing then?
That's like the Air Tag. Obviously, he's pointing down. >> That's
not Yo, I got I got ideas to do. >> Now, by the way, I
haven't looked through any of this yet. And I'm I'm
ignorant to like whether or not he's Kai is wearing that collar.
Okay. I don't >> Only way to get out of this new lie, which
is already disproven. Find this collar then in the room. You're
going to have to show it. You're going have to show it. I don't
>> And Hassan has said Kai's got multiple colors, right?
So, Lui, he already answered that. I don't know if you maybe
just got here, but the reason he said that he looked at or he
showed the other color is that there were clips. So, if you guys
remember, hold on, I'll find it for you.
>> I threw this in the Discord earlier. So, let me just
go grab the link to the best friend tweet. So, what Hassan was
saying is he felt like he needed to answer for this clip why
this clip exists.
>> So, if you notice, this is a different >> association
with Israel. So, >> and that's where the the color beeps.
So, we've got the Air Tag component and we've got the color beeping
there. Now, what XQC might not have realized is is you actually
need to flip this, right? I think did I flip it correctly? Hold
on. Did I flip it correctly? Maybe I didn't flip it correctly.
But I believe this is the buckle portion, right? So, you would
expect it to be down here. I I flipped this horizontally. Would
that work? So, we slide this onto the other side.
Either way, this is not the um
Hold on. I might have I might have done this incorrectly either
way. But then I think this this actually shows that this is not
the bad collar.
So this
you slide it to the other side. If we're looking at Ka from the
other side, although they come off and on all the time. Either
way, this is the buckle portion. I think you can see in in the
XQC picture, this is like the buckle right here with the white
pieces on the side, right?
Like this piece doesn't have anything white. It's like black.
This like silver metal. It's the buckle part there. Okay.
So, the assumption is he only has one shot collar. Well, the
assumption is that you would want the e-collar portion. It's
like the e-collar, right? So, you'd want the e-collar portion
to be there. So, if we look through the VOD, right,
we're looking we're working to disprove his fifth convoluted
lie. Wait, hold on.
Where? Where's the So, if this is true that she's not wearing
the collar, you understand that he lied about nothing,
Time for pigs.
We're We're just looking to You can literally end this entire
thing by scanning this VOD and figuring out if the dog is there
or sorry, if the uh collar is there. Like, that's all you have
to do is just go scan the VOD and see if you can find this. If
you find it, now if you don't find it, it's not necessarily dispositive,
right? But if you if you find this piece here, the whole thing
ends. Yeah. So, I just think I think that's valuable,
right? We could just immediately go and end all of the conversation
about this. The air tank part is removable. Actually, all of
the parts I believe are removable, right?
Literally, all of the parts would be removable. He'll just deny
it. So, the thing is time for pigs. There is no definitive evidence
anywhere else, right? You understand that if we were prosecuting
like a like a case, if we were doing like a beyond reasonable
doubt case, we could not put Hassan in jail for this, right?
Like we all we all understand that that he is not proven to have
done this beyond a reasonable doubt, correct?
Hold on, Dinglingus. You're just being I'm I'm asking you guys
just honestly. We We know that, right? Don't we basically know
all caller angles in the VOD? And don't we have identifi identifiable
information on the caller that day? No, we don't, Riyle. We don't
have we don't have any we the this picture this one where it
beeps this is a different day than the actual clip.
So this picture where you have the e-collar there is a different
day than than when she gets shocked and people or sorry when
she purportedly gets shocked. Oh time for pigs. I think you're
totally wrong on this.
I I listen if I had to bet on one outcome he shocked the dog
right but there's still a ton of uncertainty there. Now, he claims
the dog wasn't even wearing the collar that >> Violence.
Okay, it's the same reason. >> I believe the thing that
might make this really tough is I believe if that e-collar portion
is there, it's at the bottom of her collar. >> The why
America ka please just go just
>> you look here. This is the buckle.
>> Go just stop. And so somewhere under her chin here
would be where this e-collar portion is.
>> Oh Jesus Christ. >> Sweatpants freedom. I don't
think you would do that. Right. >> You're being such a
baby. >> Being real. It's even worse because Asan is trying
to zap even when she doesn't have the collar on apparently. Yeah.
Reaches for the Listen, Cile, that's what I think too. I agree
with you that that is the most likely outcome. But don't you
think it would be funny if we went through and and saw that it
was here and could show that as proof that like, oh yeah, Hassan's
caught now for sure. Like there is no getting out of this one.
I think that would be very valuable. But there are a lot of people
who don't want to go and look for that.
I find that interesting. Like if I were one of the people I assume
the people who go through this have some amount of intelligence
and would hear this and go, "Oh, now if I now I could have him
dead to rights on something, right?"
Wouldn't you think so?
I would think so, but maybe not. Here, I need to go find which
vaude it is here. So, let's see if we can uh we got black
It was less than two weeks ago, right?
It was his first day back from his vacation.
Is this VOD right here? Okay, so we got two VODs this day. We
got 5 hours and two hours,
right? I'm guessing it's this one. Now, this guy, what do we
>> Wait, where? >> Amazing. I had a fantastic time.
I co-streamed it alongside Pokemon. >> Okay, so we've got
Ka here.
We got Ka here. These are both the same day, I believe.
Right.
>> Your costume. Yeah. Well, >> or are they not?
Hold on. Oh, no, they're not. One is with the hat. This is without
the hat. Oh, okay. So then it's this one and this one. Oh, I
I had the wrong two VODs. Hold on. Here are the two VODs. We
want these two. The 107
the 10 seven VODs. So when he comes back is when he shocks Ka.
So basically the stream dies. We've got Ka laying here for two
hours up to that point. All
>> Oh, it certainly is. Okay. So
Well, good. But
>> we look around. Ka moves here. Whoop. Uh, you're just
>> Oh, maybe I should go find a YouTube
a commemorative mug I got from England.
that's a big movement.
That's a That's a very big movement. Oh, I'm going to have to
go find this on YouTube, though. Hold on. I'm going to have to
go find this on YouTube so we can actually scan because we're
going to have to slow it down. We're going to have to do a whole
bunch of stuff. Okay,
son. [__] VOD
107.
Okay, this would be the whole
be both.
>> It's around here where we get the uh
>> Oh,
the Hassanabi chill room. Never mind. This guy part one >> think
hate more than they care about saving Palestinians. >> And
this one cuts out. Okay. Okay. This is the This is part one.
And then we need part two here. Give me a second. We're going
to grab it. We got part one. We got part two. Okay.
Now, I understand some people might want not want to do this,
but I I just think it'd be cool if we could end this and never
have to come back to color gate again. Okay? In whatever direction
it resolves, if we could just end it, it would be nice. You know,
we kind of moving here. Okay.
>> Anti-Semitic look at what he was saying type situation.
But like
>> 18 minutes
>> Oh, what was that? What was that?
I saw a piece of the collar sticking out there.
Did I not?
Now, that's interesting, isn't it? We get that piece sticking
out here. Now, that's obviously not definitive, but it is interesting
cuz we want that big block piece to >> obviously was posting
it because she thought it it portrayed Charlie in a positive
light, but
>> uh I don't think so. No, I don't think so. I think that's
>> leaked some interesting techn.
But that's the uh the divot in the fur. >> Yeah, Norm Finkelestein
had a good dunk on Van Jones as well. I I forgot the
Now, this
we've got the air tag piece. We've got the buckle. We're looking
for a big piece sticking out there. Now, to me, if this was lined
up the same way,
we would be seeing this block here, right? Like we see here,
we would be seeing this block sticking out. Right now, hold on,
though, cuz would the block be on the other side is the question.
Is the big chunk buried by her fur? It could be.
In this I guess on this collar we've got air tag block buckle.
Air tag between the block and the buckle right man.
It's tough dude. It's tough. So you guys think this might be
it right here. The the block behind the fur >> mention
Van.
>> So then we'd have to explain why the buckle and air
tag or sorry the air tag and the Why is the Air Tag in a different
spot? We think the Air Tag got switched. What do we think here?
The Air Tag got switched over to the other side. Now, I will
say if we look at this best friend thing, I flipped the best
friend thing myself. Where's our Where's our We're looking at
this. Sorry. This one right here. So, if this turns to the other
side, we would expect
We would expect buckle.
Oh, okay. Cuz imagine Ka, you flip this over. You would expect
on the other side. This is me just flipping it horizontally,
right? But you wouldn't expect this, would you? You would expect
it to be mirrored because it's on the other side.
So, actually, I think I have to go like this.
And can I can I go selection
transform selection? Is there a way to mirror this? It's not
flip horizontally. It's like uh Oh, it's like I want to mirror.
I don't want just want to flip
Okay. Well, then if I flip horiz then it should be fine, right?
I don't need to flip vertically
because this should be how it is on the other side, right? I'm
thinking of how you'd like if you twisted this around and saw
it from the other side of the dog. Like if you if you flipped
it for the dog,
Then you'd have on the other side, you'd expect if you're looking
from the other side, the box on top, the air tag, then the buckle.
But now on this collar,
we have Air Tag buckle.
And the box you'd expect to be here, I guess, right against the
buckle, maybe.
So you maybe would expect it to be here. And the Air Tag perhaps
has been moved from this position to this >> Commemorative
mug I got from England.
Yeah, Norm Finkelestelestein had a good dunk on Van Jones as
well. I I forgot to >> see, like here, I can see that it's
not a box there, right? There is no box. It's just the hair being
pushed back, right? It's the shadows being cast by the hair being
pushed back. But we could see that there's not a box here. And
so maybe you'd expect the box to be down here, but like you guys
understand below the Air Tag. So,
but is that the case though? Again, this is me. I've I've flipped
this and I don't know if that's correct cuz you think of if you
if you were to rotate this collar around so you're seeing it
from the other side right you were to rotate this collar all
the way around so you're seeing it from the other side you would
expect box to be on top air tag to be in the middle buckle to
be here so the box is between the air tag and the buckle correct
I would expect this as well Major Dr. Gastly. So, I want you
to think, okay, you're rotating this. I know a lot of people
will have issues rotating this in their mind. Okay.
You can spin the collar and it will be opposite. Yes, exactly,
Simsy. That's what I think it will be. Right.
The the you rotate it and it will be a different setup, a different
configuration than what we're seeing in this VOD. So, there is
something to be said for Hassan saying it's a different color.
It looks like it could be. Now, did Hassan switch the order of
these things without realizing it? Like maybe, you know, if we're
thinking in the mind of the conspiratorial person who's like,
"No, Hassan clearly." Not even conspiratorial. Listen, I won't
say it's like crazy to think Hassan would have pulled the the
shock thing off and and cut the prongs off, right? It's definitely
It's definitely not
but maybe he put the maybe he put the Air Tag in a different
spot. Another angle. Doesn't look like she has the box. Okay,
hold on. Sausage.
So, this is the thing is I figured
when I heard when I heard this Hassan giving a hard claim that
she's not even wearing that, that feels like why hasn't that
VOD been torn apart by the people who hate Assan to show clearly
that she's wearing that thing? And then I realized that like
oh,
is it possible that Hassan is just
I don't I don't even know how to describe it. like so incapable
of analyzing a situation
and figuring out what to do that he didn't shock her. She wasn't
wearing the collar and he still didn't take that color off to
show people that day. It's like so stupid. It's so beyond comprehension
for almost everybody. Like and yet
are we not supposed to look at video? Are we not supposed to
take this as ground truth, guys? Shouldn't this be our ground
truth? Shouldn't this be what anchors us in the world? what we
see on the vide tape. Okay, hold on. I need to open up this uh
we had Sausage give us another link. Another time stamp here.
Give me a second. Let me scroll up to Sausage. Where are Where's
your link? I don't see it here now. Oh, I scrolled way by it.
My bad. Here we go. Let's take a look.
Another angle of her going by here. Okay,
this is another angle where we're seeing the buckle
and we would expect I guess probably you would have to you you
definitely know the box isn't there. So the box isn't set up
in the way it was on this stream. Okay, so it's either a different
collar or the collar has been reconfigured
Would you put it past to make the claim after a week since someone
pointed out to him that the VOD never shows the shock part? Nope,
I wouldn't put it past him. That's definitely still a possibility.
You can never know for sure. We can't tell. It's hidden. Well,
I'm guessing somewhere in here you should be able to see it.
Show the side by side. The side by side is misleading because
this should be in a different direction. This the side by side
is misleading here because actually given this is mirrored, right?
This is the real thing and I've just taken a screenshot of it
and I flipped it. But this is misleading because then it shows
the box on the bottom. The box should be between the box should
be above the buckle should be below
in this case. Actually, we can already say that, right? that
the buckle and the air tag are in a different order. This is
misleading. I should not actually keep that there. I should do
this. I should take this and put a screenshot of this like that.
Hold on. Cuz this is uh is misleading. Here we go. So now buckle
buckle air tag.
That does make it look
right. So here, if you were to rotate this around so it's on
Kaia's right side. If this if this buckle and air tag were on
Ka's right side instead of her left side, they would be inverted.
Correct? So, we would have buckle then air tag if it's the same
thing if it hasn't been reconfigured.
Nope. Nope. The green blinking was not noticed that day, Panub.
It was noticed on a different day. Yes. So, at minimum, you'd
have to say the color has been rearranged. Now, what we would
expect
even less. Just I need you to hold up for a second. I'll I'll
explain it one more time. Okay. If you were to rotate this collar
around Kaia's head so that the air tag and buckle are facing
the camera but on her right side instead of her left side, they
would be inverted. So the air tag would be at the top and the
buckle would be at the bottom.
Correct.
I think that is ind undeniably correct. That is just the case.
Okay.
So we would take Oh, hold on. Hold on. Why is that not showing
up? Oh, cuz I'm not moving it. So you'd expect something like
this. And then I just need uh I need another patch of fur here.
Can I get another patch of fur going?
So we'd expect something like this. Okay, we expect buckle to
be like this. God, that's not a good picture of the buckle. But
this is what you'd expect it to be like here. Actually, hold
on. That's not a good picture. We can go like this. Oh god, that's
so much worse. Oh god, we're not making it better. Okay,
whatever. Whatever. It would be something like this. Okay. Yes.
So, at minimum, this is either not the same color or it is a
color that has been altered in some way. Oh, also technically
on this picture, you'd have like the uh the buzzer up here. Okay.
Thank you, Bacto. I appreciate your nod of approval here. I think
I think we're kind of cooking potentially. I have no idea why.
I actually have no idea why Hassan wouldn't
You can customize the color part. Yeah, you could totally rearrange
it. So, that's why I'm saying just so we're clear. The position
is that either it's a different color or it has been rearranged
since. One of the two. Okay. The Air Tag probably gets moved
unless he has one for every color. Okay. Sweatpants freedom.
Let's be real. Is Hassan the guy who's going to take the Air
Tag off every time he switches her collar, which is apparently
every time he takes her out, which is every day, or is he just
going to buy another Air Tag? Like, I'm guessing he's just going
to buy another Air Tag. There's literally no reason he wouldn't
have multiple Air Tags for these things, right? You don't have
to take anything off the color collar to change the
I just You might not have to or Oh, no. But hold on. You do in
this case. No, you absolutely have to take something off of the
collar because this piece is not going to slide around freely
and the the buckle is not going to be something that this could
slide past. So, actually, you do have to take something off of
the collar in this case to change the orientation. You have to
unbuckle the collar and and like take something off. Yeah, you
absolutely do in this
So now the argument would be that it has been rearranged and
at the bottom we would expect somewhere down here the box to
be here
right
that's what we would expect now you can rotate the collar or
spin the collar think about that JTock if the air tag touches
the buckle
you don't need to change anything
what do you I don't think so no the air tag is touching on the
other color the air tag is touching this part of the
cuz you're you're not understanding.
But it's okay that you don't understand because it'll be it'll
become clear as we keep watching. You could just take the Yes,
you could. But frugals then you would expect the box to be here,
right? If you if you flipped it around, you expect the box to
be here. Yes. Like the or sorry or be down here if you flipped
it around. Sure. Sure. Sure. So you could have flipped it around.
You could have you could have taken the collar off, put it back
on um and and flipped it. You could have you you could have done
this. Yes. like by taking the color off and flipping it around.
Right.
We can't see what you're you can see what I'm pointing to. >> Van
Jones. >> Oh, I didn't have I I didn't have this selected.
Whoops. In any case, I didn't have this uh page select. >> Um
yeah, Norm Finkelestein had a good dunk on Van Jones as well.
I I forgot to mention Van Jones's. >> So there I feel like
you get a good dunk on Van Jones as well. I I forgot to >> You
get a really good look here at what's going on.
Um, I'd say this still appears to be
for all intents and purposes, I would say probably inconclusive,
right? We call that inconclusive.
It looks like there isn't something
It looks like there isn't something there, but
well, too much neck meat. But you would expect if there's something
big that sticks out here, right? Like if we're looking at something
big, this pushes the fur away, right? The fur is shorter here.
I'll give you that. The fur is shorter, but you would expect
that this is broader than the collar itself and that it wouldn't
allow the fur to overtake this.
Yes. Yeah, sure. Frugals. Yeah. Yeah, you're you're right. You're
not wrong. You're not wrong on this. That he could put it on
in a different direction each time. That would be kind of crazy
to me. But yeah, we watch this, Captain Cappy Pants. I'll be
real, Captain Cappy Pants. Um, none of the testimony from anybody
who is not Hassan makes any sense to me. It looks like they're
doing a combination of either having conversations with Hassan
and reporting thirdand basically like their Yeah, they're they're
thirdand accounts, right? Secondhand accounts, secondhand accounts.
Um, they're third party accounts is what I was trying to say.
And I don't give a They're all like they're all stupid and they're
probably mixing with stuff they've seen online as well. They're
all just stupid. They don't actually pay attention to anything.
I don't take any of them seriously. Okay.
So, I I'm just going to keep looking myself cuz it's all here.
All right.
>> Van Jones's uh clip. >> So, now we're kind of
hoping we get a view of the other side. Ka Ka has her head oriented
poorly for us to see >> Did you hear Jordan, Robin, and
Peterson is likely
>> putting together like a convincing >> We keep
we keep scrolling looking. >> At least for me, like whenever
I hear >> we got we got another Ka Switch right >> in
the aftermath of the Charlie Curse stuff. is just so
>> was the other direction. >> Crazy. So coo.
>> We do not get a >> so crazy cuck beans >> on
that side. >> But yeah, more power to her. >> This
is rough.
>> I saw a clip of Sasha Gray commenting on this and gets
owned. Well, Stingus, I just I I just want to show real quick
that that Sasha Gray clip cuz I saw it as well. You under you
understand that that's like edited to make you think that exactly
what's happening there is happening, right? like like it's edited
in a way that is punchy. You understand that, right? You could
do the like um you can do the calculus there. >> I saw
someone who provided info the caller when he showed he took out
the contact points and look put electrical tape over it. I watched
the same clip.
There are no there's no tape and you can't take those points
out. You cannot cut the prongs off of >> You can definitely
cut the prongs off. You can't remove them non-destructively,
but you can like they don't come out easily. They're not like
a thing. You destroy their capacity to work if you remove them.
>> That man, that's what I'm saying. The cope is so hard
with a lot of people on >> Like the electric prongs are
taken out of it. >> But here's my thing, right? >> Yeah.
I don't know if cutie is talking about um I don't know what cutie
means
but I lean in this direction that it probably was the one that
had the prongs before. Yeah. Yeah, Asia, we we all agree 100%.
100% that the prongs could be easily removed. They just can't
be non-destructively removed, right? Proved you can cut them.
You can still shock. Even with them cut, you can still shock.
Okay. So, they still they still do the attempts machine stuff.
Even if you cut Okay, then you can't scroll. So, would that work
on a dog though? Can you tell me like would that actually work
on a dog? Oh, is joking by the way. Bacto's memeing. We know
who is here.
you you can't the only point we're making is you can't temporarily
cut them off. Uh we've always agreed here that you could cut
them off and that he could have easily done that after the stream
to try to avoid controversy.
Yeah. Yeah.
100%.
Wait, is he still in the hospital bed? >> Oh, he is. Yeah.
>> We have another instance of Kai getting up over here
by
>> Let's take a look.
If you truth her to say that >> oh that that should be
like the best shot we get of that and it's too small
>> that Mcronone's wife is kind of twisting around the
other way right
>> leaning out the other way we can't even see at all the
collar here which is interesting maybe 2754 here
on which one is that the next one or is that the current one
hold on I can't open the thing is I can't open out of that chat
very easily. Oh, that's over in Twitch chat either or that's
out of Twitch chat, too. Okay,
awesome. Let's see this
>> land specifically.
>> No, thank you. So, this is 1805 on this one. I think
this was the one we had up
>> Now, hold on. 1805 on part one. Part
>> So, this should be 1805 on this vaude. It should line
up pretty close, right?
1651. It should line up exactly. So, 1805 here. got from England
specifically
for uh for when I was there when he was got from England. England.
>> I don't think we I don't think we get very much here.
Oh,
look. She moves pretty quick.
Now here, like is that possible that on the top there? That's
it. You do see more on the bottom here as well. Is that a box?
Is that a box? I'm trying to see what is like shadow or not shadow
or like what this is here. Could that be it? Could that be it
here? Let me zoom in more. Let me zoom in more. Okay,
there's a hole. No. Um,
possibly. It's hard to tell if uh it's hard to tell if there's
like a if you're seeing the back of the bed or what here, man.
That's uh that's very not definitive here. Oh, I guess you do
see a little bit of the bed reaching up. So, it's hard to tell
where the collar ends
and the bed begins, right?
because you see a frame of bed sticking through here. Oh, if
you look here, if you look next day. Okay, hold on. Can we get
the next day VOD then? So, we got a message here from Accelerate.
If you look next day, you can see it's very obvious when she's
got that part of the collar on. So, let's look at next day.
Next day. And you gave me the time stamp. 1 hour 4541.
1 hour 4541.
>> Is insane. Even
>> this guy who is like a relatively
>> Wait, what? What do you mean next day? >> In closing,
what I wanted to >> this uh >> Wait, what? Cellerati,
it's not the next day. Which day are you doing?
You sending me a VOD link?
Hold on. Stop sending me VOD links to Twitch. Okay, go here.
Hold on. Let me put this in the chat. If you guys want to follow
along, you want to look for your own stuff here. Okay, we're
looking at the VODs part one and part two. October 7th VODs here
on YouTube if you want to join in. Okay. Try to use YouTube stuff
cuz you can't scan through frame by frame here.
>> So we got 1 hour 8 here. So 8 days ago
1 hour Oh god. What did you say? Accelerate. We need to take
another look. 1 hour 4541.
>> Simply engaging in anti-fascist demonstrations.
If you
>> It seems obvious like on there and it's now air tag
buckle block here as well which is again the same the same configuration
again right it's air tag >> it's it's the e-collar tight
to the air tag tight to the buckle again
>> people who are are anti-fascist >> we all see
this >> simply engaging in anti fascist demonstrations
here let's slow it on.
But when we look, this is next day. It's air tag
collar buckle and this is not able to be covered at all. Buckle,
air tag, e-collar. Yes. On the other side, right? Or is this
this is what we're looking at next day. Okay. So, it's either
way it's buckle, air tag, e-collar. It doesn't matter cuz you
could put it on whichever way, right? You can flip it,
right? It just depends on how you put it on.
But this one's buckle air tag e-collar. We We don't need to What
we want to see is it's always going to be air tag tight to buckle
tight to
this block. All right.
So that tells us that in in this VOD on these VODs you would
expect air tag and then it to be here
>> from England.
>> What I don't necessarily get is why you can't ah why
you going so fast Ka? I don't get why you can't see it sticking
the fur back in the same way.
Right. So, here the buckle and the air tag are pushing the fur
away. It seems like when the when the e-collar is there,
the buckle, sorry, the uh the hair is pushed away pretty significantly
because it overreaches the the actual collar significantly. If
he took the collar off to take off the prongs and put it back
on the same day, it would sit on the fur and not dig under it
possibly. Um, maybe.
Yeah, maybe. I would say just in general, like depending on how
it's originally put on and what you do that day, it could, you
know, bury further into refer or not. Space Ghost, I criticize
XQC for saying things without thinking them through, just so
you know.
Does he change colors? He says he changes colors all the time,
right? He says Ka has multiple collars. He changes colors all
the time. And he says he said specifically Ka was not wearing
the e-collar that day. Yeah. I I kind of a agree with you, Major
Dr. Gassley, that it looks like it's possible she wasn't wearing
that collar that day. Now, this makes it even worse for Hassan
in terms of his instincts, his self-preservation instincts, his
rational understanding of how people of just the average person
and how they would observe these things. It makes it so much
less forgivable that he wouldn't take the collar off if he's
just 100% innocent and could have solved that for himself, right?
Not that he should have to, but it's just like, bro, how do you
not know when you're a big creator that you could just preserve
so much right now by taking this off and showing it? >> Mentioned
Van Jones's uh clip
as well. >> Now, we're still looking through
here. We get full screen.
>> Made a living for many, many years talking about how
nationalism isn't a dirty word. But at least he's smart enough
not to associate it with Germany. He will always say
We don't see Ka move for quite a while here. Ka's just chilling.
A >> man by the name of Vladimir Ilich Lennon as a matter.
However, a Bill Clinton >> Now, the one thing is is the
way I'm looking through this, we are not necessarily,
okay, we're not necessarily going to grab the best views
of Kai. Like I think there should be at some point if Ka yawns,
dogs tend to put their heads up when they yawn. So, it feels
like we should be looking for a yawn here, right? This just seems
like a pirate software situation where we would keep doubling
down, not come clean. I would agree with you if he shocked the
dog, if the dog was wearing the collar,
I I would maybe agree with that. I think probably most likely
situation here is the dog was shocked the first day. I don't
think it's definitive. I don't think it's like 100%. I don't
think you could even convict somebody on this if it were to,
let's say, happen in a criminal court. It's not happening in
criminal court. We don't need that burden of evidence for the
public. Not suggesting that. I'm just saying that I think it's
not quite reached that level of evidence.
said that he said >> so at some point here you would expect
Kai to yawn or something right and to show that underside of
her >> relationship who the [__] does he think
he is Clinton reportedly bellowed who's the superpower here
>> so we're just looking for her to move
>> she is laying back here >> is it possible we've
got something there on top >> is a
Bill Clinton is because like
uh that is that you >> never jtock it's a prop all it has
to do is stay still. That's not true. >> There throughout
>> Kai is the most study dog on the planet. Well, here's
the thing, my doll hairs. If people were just like Hassan lost
his temper and the dog yelped and he didn't go check on it and
he's kind of being a dick in that situation, what happened? If
they like stopped there, it would be fine. But they're a bunch
of like really big influencers like Techone, like absolute pieces
of totally totally reprehensible human beings who will go through
this and try to paint Hassan as somebody who needs to have his
dog taken away, right? and paint this as like a grand conspiracy.
So now I have every incentive in the world to go and say, "Well,
that seems really unhinged. You constantly lie and make things
up in other situations. Why don't I go take a look and see what
I can find here?"
About time
again. So many red. >> I'm moving her head here a little
bit. >> Doctrine on October.
>> Kyle looking around >> straight up part of his
up. Dude, this dog's got way too much neck meat and >> fur
bottom there. Will you look at look at as she like looks up there
utilized on October 7th. We know this because the defense secretary
at the time you have gant international work you have
>> you'll never see anything under this dog has way too
much. There's just way too much there. Right. You're just never
going to ever see the underside.
It's fat. I don't even know if it's fat. That's how these dogs
tend to look like like she's very hairy. I don't I don't know if
she's fat at all. a lot
openly admitted to the utilization
of the Hannibal. >> I like that when her when her hair
is like this, it's almost like a lion's mane, isn't it? Can you
see how it like fans out all around the the collar here? Right.
It's kind of got like It's kind of like a lion.
It's got like a lion's >> doctrine on October 7. Situation
is a deliberate reason. Real >> puts her head down. Okay.
interest in. So like I could see somebody thinking maybe that
could be >> It was genuine like the that a lot of the major
narrative they were driving >> standing here to see if
we find
remember. So a
whether you should do that or not I'm not go I'm not
relitigating that. Okay.
But it is obvious that there is not only an asymmetry
with the ways >> in which Israel >> are we going
to >> gets to do whatever the it wants.
>> It chips away uh throughout
not moving. Not changing. Oh, we got a we got movement. We have
movement.
There's the yawn that I was hoping for. The yawn does not occur
while the dog is up in any way.
>> Pollution. Okay. Oh man,
I feel like you should be able to see the thing sticking out
given how it sticks out on other days, right? >> If he
does not want to engage this hard truth, he should just be silent.
The Palestinians are not political pawns for him to use or condemn
based on the >> Very true, Mad Slice. I think both sides
of this drama can agree that Hassan should shave Ka's fur before
just zapping before zapping day to make the case clear. Yes.
>> Exigencies of electoral politics, solidarity or nothing.
Does this not concern you? It does.
Uh, it concerns me twofold.
Relevant tweet. Hold on. The same people telling you to believe
Hassan's friends to believe Hassan's friend that he's a good
dog owner are the same people who told you not to listen to my
two roommates that I had was an amazing boyfriend. Everything
that Hassan has used against people is now absolutely him in
the apps. Wait, but there does does Teto not realize that there's
a human being with a consciousness?
He actually doesn't realize that there's a human being with like
a consciousness that exists that's accusing him of the crimes,
right?
And the rest of us are all just using like a video
for the Kaya case for Techone. There's there's a human being
and not just one but two who are accusing of abusive behaviors.
Right. This is this is like a totally wild tweet to make. Uh,
thank God he's got me blocked for his sake, okay?
Because he's actually totally
shocking that Teeone still after all this time doesn't consider
either of his exes human beings worthy of being listened to.
Amazing. Amazing.
Incredible stuff from Techone.
Not shocking anybody >> because this is a guy who is literally
been hounded by
Oh man, you got to believe that if that block is there, it would
be poking through and showing with that shot, right? You got
to believe if that block is there, it's going to show there,
right, bro?
We can see now that it's not on the top, right? We can now see
that officially we can rule it out being on top. I think that
it is flat to the collar. There is no block for the e-collar
sticking out here at all. Oh, look, it's there. Wait, are you
are you That's not it. You understand that this is the Air Tag,
Hold on. One nerf. You understand that this is the Air Tag and
not a part of the e-collar, correct?
Surely you wouldn't be in my chat making comments while not understanding
that this is not in fact a part of the e-collar in any way. Go
back a few frames.
Go back a few frames. Do you think this is it on top without
sticking out at all? So, we think that this thing, >> all
this does is >> that sticks out like hugely that we get
Oh, sorry.
Positive association. >> This thing that sticks out massively,
right? This big block of thing with a with a green light flash.
I got it.
>> We think that that
is what's
like here. This flat thing. >> This thing that doesn't
stick out at all. We think that's what that is there.
So, now it doesn't stick out at all. I just I'm My argument here
is that there's no depth to it, right? His friends already said
it's a shock collar. Well, he owns the shock part of the collar
deaf tie, right? He owns he owns some collar where you could
remove the prongs from the shock piece and it's an e-collar.
But what he said is Ka was not even wearing the e-collar collar
this day. That she has multiple collars and she was not wearing
an e-collar this day. So yeah, I'm like I'm not uh
like I have no doubt that he owns the e-collar, but if she's
not wearing the e-collar on this day,
see this is what I I see a lot of deaf deaf tai is I see people
saying things like this. It's so sus and he mismanaged it to
make it easier to think he's nefarious. It's like yes, but you
understand that doesn't make him nefarious, right? That him being
like a total [__] doesn't doesn't make him actually
nefarious. And before, you know, taking his dog from him or suggesting
for people to take his dog from him, I'd like to know which one
it is. Was he doing something bad? Was he not doing something
bad? What is actually happening? I feel like that's just important
for us to look at this and figure it out. That's how I feel,
man. That's what I think. Okay. Well, all this does is breed
resentment
against Israel and also depending on how
Hey Ka, what are you doing? Ka, what are you doing? So, in any
case, um the reason why he pulled off the other one, I think
what he's saying is one, people had posted this clip to show
that he has the e-collar, right?
And then two,
because um because XC had offered $50,000 if he just pulled it
off and showed it to the stream. Yeah. Well, luckily for us,
by the way, this isn't even a good argument because very luckily
for us, we have like hundreds or thousands of hours of Ka being
in that room. I've yet to see another abusive situation happen
in that room or something that you could say was even like a
possibly abusive act if you could form a pattern of it. Right.
That's that's probably my reason for feeling like this should
be he should be defended on just his dog ownership is that over
thousands of hours
he's like love this dog taking care of this dog. There's no other
instance of him losing his temper in this way and being annoyed
with the dog because he's annoyed himself with his tech issues.
There's like every bit of evidence in the world that this is
aberant behavior on his part and no evidence that it's a part
of a larger pattern or any problems over time forcing your dogs
to rest spot to be in a bright loud room to impress your viewers.
I mean I don't know about you shag it up but around co the dog
that I had really wanted to be in my office with me when I was
home. Maybe you've had dogs that don't want to be in the office
with you don't want to be around you but that's the opposite
of my experience
personally.
Um, so I I don't know. I can't empathize with the person who
is like, "My dog doesn't want to be near me when I'm at home
doing work." Right. I don't still have a dog. No, the room is
gated, so it has no choice. Yes. But here's the thing is he's
obviously not going to let the dog in and out of the room, right?
And he's already explained a couple of the reasons why the dog
doesn't flow in and out of the room and why the dog has to stay
in place. It is not I it is not disputed that this dog laying
on the hard floor would cause joint issues and possibly like
form like arthritis over time, right? Nobody's actually disputed
that. Nobody's questioned that the big dog laying on the hard
floor would be bad. So, if you let the dog come in and out in
this hardwood floor house, that would be a problem for this dog
over time. Okay.
So, he wants the dog to lay on the bed. Now, probably the best
thing he could do for the dog is get sort of like a fenced in
area where he could put like soft stuff down for the dog's joints.
Maybe that would be the best case scenario. I don't think this
is a horrifying compromise. It doesn't seem that bad to me. She's
not kept there the whole day. She gets tons of exercise, right?
Like this dog does get enough exercise every single day from
all indication. Might as well create the dog in another room.
I mean, you could do that, but I just don't I don't see how that's
tangibly different from this. Can you check here?
Oh, you gave me another time stamp. 1 hour 58 on this one.
Can you check here? So, this is October 7th. This is when he
comes back. 1 hour 58. Okay. 1 hour 58 flats.
You check here. Ooh, this is a good view. This is a good view.
This is good looking out. Okay. Make sure we're all the way up.
We're up to maximum resolution
>> $800 billion.
>> Maximum resolution. Okay. Are we seeing any good >> Wait,
didn't she also work at DY Marjorie Taylor Green? No. >> Worth
noting that even if there is any >> I'm not seeing good
views of it here.
>> Pull in the law that would pre prevent this money from
going to federal workers after the shutdown. Cong. >> Oh,
that's an interesting view. Ooh, man. I can't tell. That's really
hard to tell if we could see anything there at all. I got to
believe that because the Air Tag is forcing the fur outwards
that if the box were right here somewhere, it would be forcing
the fur outward in a similar way,
right?
>> I think I see a bump >> could easily close that
loophole in whatever bill they
scary. >> So, here's the other thing is we should probably
be seeing since we know Kasan hasn't touched the collar.
Why wouldn't we see the green light? Is the green light on >> positive
association with Israel
>> green light on the green light is on the underside it
looks like. Okay
does is >> so we would I didn't go back far enough we expect
to see that green light right
right there we'd expect to be see this green light at some point
potentially
maybe it might be too low there or it might be on the if it's
on the
Yeah, if it's Although, wait, are we we're in the flipped orientation
here, right? I think we're in the flipped orientation where the
buckle's on the other side. So, no, we would expect it to be
on the top in this case, right? The Air Tag holder can slide
around the collar. Why would the Air Tag holder be able to slide
over the buckle or over this part of the collar? No, we're in
the flipped orientation or else the the air or else this has
to be it goes buckle air tag
e-collar, right? Oh, I'm not saying this is mirrored. I'm saying
we're in the flipped orientation cuz we're on the other side
of Kaia's body
right? When we're in the scratching, when we're looking at the
scratching clip, we're on the other side of Kaia's body. We're
on her right side here, whereas here we're on her left side.
But in any case, even if it maybe that's not as tangible, but
we have uh we have e-collar tag buckle. We do not expect the
airller or sorry, the air tag to move between the buckle and
the the
We don't expect this at all. Yes, it can. Google. Yes, it can.
Wait, why would it be able to slide over the
This wouldn't make any sense. Hold on, Google. Why don't you
Google something and show me? Uh, Beck does over in the Twitch
chat says, "I don't care about internet drama, but was bored
scrolling through Twitter and Teone is literally obsessed with
Assan. It's actually crazy and should be studied. This can't
be healthy." I don't mind him being obsessed. I just think you
should make claims that you could back up. And Teone's never
been concerned with doing that, right?
Like, ever. Teton's just literally never ever been concerned
with doing that and it is just vengeance for him against Hassan,
right? He was forced to tears by Hassan and he wants some kind
of vengeance back. >> It's a scary time for so many families.
All right, that Ryan, thank you. >> So, I think I personally
think there's every reason to believe Air Tag
uh buckle and this should be the e-collar if it >> Hey,
thanks for watching and don't forget you can catch the >> and
we don't see it. We don't see it protruding from the fur at all.
Like look here how it pushes the fur back in a similar way to
the Air Tag. The Air Tag, the buckle, and the e-collar all push
fur away because they're flat to the collar and they're wider
than the collar, but we don't see that phenomenon happening in
this case
show every morning. >> Now, it's possible Kai's fur is
just >> on NBC or
Oh, that shake should have given us a good look. We have to go
back. We have to slow-mo the shake. Oh, artifacting is getting
us here. Oh, the the artifacting can't handle. I don't know if
we can make any Is this a thing? I don't know if this is like
It seems like you could almost say that this could be, but then
it could just be the color moving around played on YouTube. This
is YouTube.
>> This is YouTube. If only Kaio was obeying the laws of
physics and not moving faster than light in any given moment
in time. >> If you
Oh, this is uh this is the next day. Okay. The color she's actually
wearing, right? So, this is supposed to be our view of >> how
it moves the fur back. Okay.
>> So, this is next day where we know >> people who
are literally know that she's wearing the collar on this day,
right? This is the day that pulls it off and shows us.
>> So, when you want to look at this, go
>> When you want to look at this,
>> it's buckle air tag
e-collar. Okay. So, it pushes the fur away a little bit. We see
it like burrow out here pretty
>> So, what are we going through? We're going scratch >> every
morning on NBC. >> Is that the best view?
>> Or take
when you're on the >> That could be that could be your
best view when you're on the color side on NBC or
>> there's like a there's a there's a frame here that shows
like a boxish looking thing there. Is this it? That can't be
it. I think we saw Air Tag. This one, this one right here would
be your best hope for a view, but I don't know if you could tell.
It looks like the Air Tag Oh, this might not save you if you're
on the e-collar side, right? Cuz the Air Tag itself is the same
size as the box here. And I think we could see in the other views
that that's not the case that the Air Tag is like slim.
Yeah, the Air Tag is
Mano. That that could be there. That could be there.
Zoom in. You're just wrong. my doll hairs. Keep saying the same
wrong thing over and over again. I'm sure it will change everyone's
opinion. Uh we see this exact same orientation in multiple clips
where the where the tag doesn't move between the buckle and the
e-collar from multiple different days, right? Uh it's probably
all of these things. American swag.
It's probably all of these things.
Yeah. So, you could keep saying the wrong thing that's clearly
wrong, but we can see in every other case that this is not happening,
right? What's up, dickers? How's it going? The Dickers crew rolling
in now. Yeah. I This is how I feel. Major Dr. Gastley. It's just
It's hard to get any definitive look at this, right? This is
the 18-minute version. I should have been timestamping these.
Hold on. I'm actually Listen, we're going to We're going to get
uh
I'm going to keep track of these in a document. Color views.
We got this time
We've got this time stamp. Okay. We've got these two time stamps
that we're working with so far. I tried to link it, didn't work.
Go over to the Discord.
Hop in there. Throw links in there. We can find them. Go to chat.
Uh because TYT uh interviews her. That's it. She's not actually
>> We're going to begin though with >> Oh. Uh we
will also check out the Dan breakdown. But I don't know I don't
know if the damn breakdown's going to give us new information
cuz I basically said exactly what he proved. I'm like it would
be super easy with just bolt cutters or he didn't even need bolt
cutters in this in this case. He just had um like wire wire cutters,
right? Like on pliers. He just had like wire cutters and those
were able to cut through them.
the Alpard round the world still going. Well, listen
for everybody who wants to know, Sugarlocks. Okay, Hzan gave
us something where we could probably definitively push back and
prove that he shot Ka or that he didn't. >> Also, ATC
has been uh suffering from the government shutdown.
>> Nashville air traffic control was shut down for 5 hours
tonight. >> Grab some water real quick. >> The air
traffic control near Burbank. >> I'm going to use the bathroom.
Grab some water. What could we do? We could watch some clips
in the meantime. I've got some clips that we wanted to watch.
We got the Dan stuff. Here's uh here's Sneo's thoughts. Okay,
Sneo's thoughts on how this is shaking up the Twitch aristocracy.
Okay, >> so funny about >> We got a minute five.
I should be back by then. I should be close. I'll be right back.
>> The dog shock situation is seeing all the perfect moral
high ground LA slop tubers and streamers have to defend Hassan
because that's one of their own. and Pokemon cancels a podcast
with him because she doesn't want to face any backlash because
she's not a real friend and won't stand by him when he's facing
controversy. Says, "Oh, it wasn't me. It was my team who took
it down." Okay, then post a podcast. Stop being a crybaby. Stop
being a just just release the podcast with your friend if you're
a real one. And the rest of them saying, "No, it wasn't a shot
caller. He taped over the shock part and it was vibrating." Yeah.
What type of millionaire buys a shot collar to tape it over?
They're just admitting that he was actually electrocuting his
dog like a Sith Lord, unknowingly incriminating Hassanabi in
the situation. Nobody's ever bought a shot caller just to not
use it, just to only use the vibration feature. I love that it's
animal abuse that's taking them all down and showing that this
LA cabal of slot tubers and streamers, they all pretend to be
like good people and now the domino effect is crumbling. It's
all being exposed that they're really just playing a character.
Oh man. Oh man.
That's got to be rough to hear Sneo get so many things wrong
in such a short period of time and then to just totally echo
techone otherwise. It's almost like these people don't really
care about being correct
at all. Uh Pokey didn't cancel that to hurt Hassan cuz she was
trying to distance. She did that because she's friends with say
actually guys you're donated $3
still feeling the aftershocks. I see. >> Thank you Reuben.
Ruben. Reuben. Rubin's the only person who's allowed to make
puns about this. If any of you do it, you will be banned swiftly.
Okay. You will be exited. We will we will remove you from the
chat. All right. Okay.
We continuing. We are continuing. All right. So, that's that's
Sneo's opinion. He got literally nothing correct there. I don't
It's kind of rough, man.
You're shock shocked that Sneo got nothing correct. Also banned.
Okay, what do we have? We've got a couple other clips. Maybe
we could check out some of these. We did the Sasha Gray one.
Um
there's some denims one. Somebody said age like milk was I believe
the uh the LSF thread title. Okay. >> First of all, the
product can't
be turned into a vibrating caller for starters. Second,
the taped photo is [__] doctor. Dude, you fell for
misinfo.
>> Yeah, I don't know, bro. I Hassan got to pay some better
people, man. There's got to be a better way. They just like this
is this is rough. Okay, so for everybody who felt bad about Sneo
being on their side, I can feel like Denim's kind of taking the
more empathetic. Hassan's probably not that bad side. Dude, why
would you do this? Why would you just make things up? Like, why
would you just lie? She just lies to cover for him. Yeah, she
just lies. That's so that's so bad. It makes you look so bad
and unreliable to people. >> Congratulations, bro. this
image, you can clearly see the tape. The tape image is a doctorred
photo. I took this from the VA directly.
And when you look at the
apparently the Air Tag is supposed to slide over these buckles
somehow,
despite it being seemingly fairly tightly secured here, we're
supposed to just have that Air Tag slide across. I don't know.
Ftier Janies. Listen,
these people are actually a scup, okay? Denims has been working
to take Hassan down from moment one. She's become his strongest
defender so that she could just start stroking out live on screen
>> artifacting on these photos. It's very obviously a [__]
Photoshop job. Like you literally fell for misinfo. Congrats.
You can just hate us on by the way. You can just say I don't
like him.
>> Um yeah, this looks this looks really bad when people
are willing to just lie and make things up, right? It just looks
it looks horrible. I almost understand if you're if you're stuck
in like certain bubbles on Twitter. I can almost understand how
you see denims do this and you're like, "Oh, I guess only I guess
people have to like lie totally to try to defend Hassan, right?
Dan has been 85% since this all started with no signs of going
down. Listen, at some point you got to respect Dan's grind. Okay?
How
why should Dan stop when when he is rewarded massively at all
times for doing this?
There's literally no incentive to make him stop at all. There's
every incentive for him to keep going,
right? Like nobody nobody cares if he's unhinged. Uh he is probably
more accurate. Like even though even though Dan is deranged,
okay, going to going at Hassan pretty objectively like kind of
deranged.
Uh he's far more accurate than Denims, right? I would rather
have Listen, I'll take the person who's going to put in the work
regardless of how silly their their their beef seems, right?
Their vendetta.
>> Dan is putting in work or he's he's paying other people
to put in work. Either one.
But Denims is
this is just lazy. Too bad. Okay.
Are we are we still scrolling through these? This is the second
This is a two out of two VOD.
One out of two VOD. Okay. We were scrolling through this. Where
did we end up on this?
This is a different day. Was
this where we were? This is us getting through the first VOD
mostly looking for where's where where Kai has moved and right
these other
>> So here's the thing. >> We definitely don't expect
if the e-collar is here for it not to push any fur away. Right.
This is the problem is we don't have any bulky push out here
from what we think is the e-collar in other pictures.
>> This is this is the rough part. If you think that this
is the e-collar, right, it's not pushing the fur away at all.
It's sort of just getting enveloped. Even though it seems from
all indications that this piece sort of knocks the fur down anywhere
it's it's put on >> other places.
Although I didn't
can miss and all
these
she pulls away.
Yeah. I just don't see it. Okay. >> [__] places
in perpetuity.
uh for >> anything on the other side his consistent advocacy
for the Palestinian
>> They're not gonna [__] turn around and all
of a sudden be like, "Yeah, this Muslim guy who was an anti-ionist
for his entire activism is is is all of a sudden uh good now."
You know what I
>> Yeah. Mahmood >> movement again. See,
>> there is no symmetry. And as long as you do not actually
address that there is no symmetry here >> it looked like
on top we got a little bit of a look at the thing like something
portraying here but I can't >> was a
breaking point after the culmination of >> thank you
>> like here oh it's just the the collar again so could
this be it oh it's not Wait that's not even collar that's like
does she have a black spot of hair there
is that like dark hair. Oh, that's not even No, I don't think
that's I don't think Yeah, sure it can be. But this right here,
can you see it? This is like fur. Yeah, that's like a That's
like fur right there. That's uh Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But that's
what it looks like is happening here, right? The color is under
there. No, it's not. Watch her turn. You can see the color here.
This is like This is like fur and the color is clearly here.
And you can see a differentiation. this light bit of hair
right from away from this collar
even it could be a shadow either way it's it's not so I thought
maybe you had a chance at on top here this fur piece being the
e-collar but it's clearly not right it's clearly not on top now
we expected it to be down below anyway right we totally expected
it to be down here because we expect the e-color air tag buckle
thing is going to last is going to sit on this Okay.
How many hours of content can you possibly milk out of this dog?
Well, unfortunately for Hassan, he's got nobody who's not a lazy
piece of totally like a total barnacle who's like not going to
put any work in. He's only got people who are lazy defending
him. Okay, so we're going to do a little bit of work. We're going
to put a bare minimum in bare minimum effort, okay, to just see
if we can find any exculpatory evidence on this day. Cuz honestly,
I just feel bad for the guy. He's being called a dog abuser.
Honestly, if they're just like he lost his temper and he didn't
even give a that his dog yelped, that's all fine. Yeah, he was
an Yeah, he was he needs to be chastised for being a dick on
that day. Jaw keeps making money, do we? Do I'm I'm unaware of
this. I'm unaware of this, but maybe uh you're trying to defend
him. I'm trying to just I listen what I see
is Hassan is basically like a black person on trial during Jim
Crow. And it's like, listen, you could you could say you don't
want him to have a defense because you hate him, but I believe
that, you know, all humans are created equal, and I believe that
they should get the best defense no matter what. And not a single
person wants to do it on his side, right? So, I just I just want
to go through and like watch.
Hello, hyperbolic. Okay.
I I It really do be like that though, right? It really do be
like that. Well, it's not sweeping even rain. I'm literally going
through and I'm asking people what they think is going on,
right? You are totally deranged. But that's okay. You could just
hate Hassan and not contend with any facts. Just, you know, suck
your thumb, get a bottle. I hate Hassan. Hassan's really bad.
You can sit there and do that. It's totally fine, man.
Listen, I can't defend his behavior in terms of like making himself
look good in terms of how he handled this optically. Can't defend
that. All I'm trying to see is if this guy's actually in any
way like should I suspect he's abusive of this dog. Also,
also there's a little intuition on my part that when he gives
a definitive way to prove that he shocked the dog and nobody
approaches that, nobody actually goes through this VOD and checks
to see if it's true.
So, hold on, Latigious Gamer, you're here late. I think a bunch
of people are here late. Do I have to go through the whole theory
here again?
So the theory is essentially Hassan himself
says that Kaia wasn't wearing her e-collar on the day that on
the day Color gate erupted. >> Third group of people are
the ones who are like look at this clip. Look at >> now
when he says that that gives people something tangible that is
easily disprovable, right?
And it has not been disproven. That is a hard claim that has
not been disproven at all. Okay. Uh, did we check?
Verdict on that VOD. Uh, I we did the sh the headshake. I don't
think there's anything definitive there. So,
again, anal sex, I'm just going to actually block you so I don't
see you whining. Um, you can still talk in the chat. I'm just
You're not going to show up on my chat. Um, so I don't have to
see it cuz you're just saying the same thing. You're just saying
the same thing over and over again. If you want to make an argument
instead of just like venting emotionally, that's totally fine.
You can join the Discord or you can just make an argument. But
if you just want to vent emotionally, I don't want to see that
because it actually is distracting when you do it in all caps.
So he says here that she's not even wearing the e-collar on this
day. And so when nobody when nobody goes and posts a clip of
her clearly wearing the e-collar on this day, I go, "Oh, cuz
I assume they looked, right?
I assume they looked."
It gives me like a little intuition that like, oh, I wonder if
there's just nothing there that day or if there's some definitive
proof that it's not the >> Look at that clip. Look at this
clip. like it's obvious he's moving his arms around like he's
he's
constantly in a state of of of zapping. And um they've moved
away from the
uh conversation which was >> they moved away from the conversation
which was that like >> she didn't even have that collar
on to begin with. And the only reason why I showed the collar
was because
>> she didn't even have that collar on to begin with. And
when I look it seems like for us
for us it seems like
I'm having a hard time seeing it. Why show it? >> Clicking
other
>> Right. So when everybody's arguing, when XQC is arguing,
when XQC slows this down and he shows this uh this collar light
up, right? And he goes, "Oh, Hassan, you're guilty." Hassan goes,
"Oh, here's this collar." He pulled the collar off that she had
on and he showed it. That's that's his argument, right? Was these
were getting clipped, so he showed this this screenshot
or sorry, he showed this collar that she had on at the time.
I roll I
I'll I'll just direct all of you guys, okay? I I'll just direct
you guys to the obvious fact that he's given you something conclusive
that you can just if you can show the e-collar on this day, you
win. Hassan falls. It's over for Hassan. He is directly lied.
He has provably lied, right? None of the rest of this stuff is
provable. You are filling in your bias to close the gap between
the evidence you think is conclusive and like what everybody
or the average person could easily find conclusive. Right? I'd
pay for this level of sweeping. Okay. Just explain to me where
I've said something incorrect, even less.
Right? Have any tangible disagreement instead of venting your
emotions like a toddler? And I'm totally happy to respond to
that.
But you vent your emotions like a toddler instead of making an
argument. you you can't you can't see it, right? I I'll just
contend with any argument I made. Contend with anything I've
said, but if if you just want to vent emotions, that's okay.
That's fine. The chat is a place for that, too. Does a son have
two colors? Apparently, he has multiple colors. Yes. He said
he said I've seen the clips. I don't know where they are. I don't
have the clips off the top of my head that he has multiple colors
with the air tags on them. My points are he just showed a shot
collar. No explanation for that. Well, he's got an e-collar.
Yes, he has an e-collar with apparently the electrodes taken
off. Whether it happened before or after, it's hard to say, but
you understand that if you can't show this e-collar at all on
the day of, that's a little suspicious. No. Anyway, I'm That's
all we're doing right now is just slowly moving through all of
the evidence to try to see,
hey, where can we where can we find this e-collar in these VODs?
Also, you would expect to see the green light turn on on one
of these from one of these angles. Yes. And by the way,
uh, I don't have the requisite psych degrees to go
I don't have the requisite psych degrees to go and figure out
and explain to
why Hassan defended himself so poorly here or why Hassan wouldn't
have just said, "No, she wasn't even wearing that collar from
the first part." I have no idea. I don't have that. So, I'm just
looking for this because it could just be definitive, right?
Does the E-colar have the green light? Yes, it does. This is
the E-colar right here that has the green light on it. Yep. This
this has the green light. This is the one he showed to the stream,
right? The reason is because he's guilty. Okay, Peanut. Then
we should be able to find some picture of it here, right? On
the day of, we should be able to see it.
That's I'm just looking for it, right?
And I find it very interesting that people have to vent their
emotions instead of making arguments, right? I saw a couple people
came in and they made arguments and I contended with those arguments.
If you're just getting emotional because I'm looking into this,
I think that's something you should look internally at at why
you'd be getting emotional about it. Why you wouldn't be, you
know, trying to make an argument, trying to say, well, this fact
makes me look in the opposite direction, right?
You're just getting like emotional.
Time stamp. Do you want This is, by the way, this is on a different
day. This is on a very different day.
A very different day. Is this the next day? Hold on. Is this
the next day? Is that the same outfit? No, it's not. Okay, this
is next day when she is clearly wearing the collar again. Okay,
Dinglingus,
where where am I lying to your face? I have my 51%. Yeah, I agree
with you, Peanut, that maybe balance of probability. I lean in
this direction as well. But I think it's interesting given how
many people are going so aggressively in the opposite direction.
I think it's interesting that nobody's looked into this thing
where they could easily just categorically show that he is a
liar. He can't be trusted at all. Uh Hassan's like dead. If you
find that green light going off in one of these VODs, it's over
for Hassan. Like, it's actually over. This guy is done at that
point. Then he's just been lying the whole time. And you have
conclusive evidence of his lies. Not conclusive evidence that
like he's misstating or like might be misleading or that he's
making bad choices. Not conclusive evidence of those things,
but conclusive evidence that he is overtly lying, that he's totally
making things up in order to try to defend himself. Now,
very different thing.
All right. Whereabouts were we into this VOD? We're here. Hour
30.
All right. So, hour 30. We're seeing
we're seeing that the thing that on top looked like it could
be possibly the e-collar. That's just fur. So, we've lost any
hopes. The the top the people betting on top. All right. They
have lost entirely.
It's over for them. Does he not have the color green light on
in the VOD where Ka yelped? No. Fire. And no, that is a different
VOD. In fact, this is a different VOD. And apparently uh you
know, Babka said it. I I have not confirmed this, but Babka says
that he was responding to this clip and XQC was referring to
this clip when Hassan responded and said, "Here's the caller."
I took it takes it off and shows it.
What day is it? This is just a different day with the green light.
So, we're just looking through. We're We're trying to take a
look and we're doing it calmly and we're doing it without freaking
out. Yeah, I agree with you, Hamster. I agree with you. This
is a good time. We love We love looking into things. Okay, we're
just investigating. What are lab's thoughts on shock collargate?
I think her thoughts were I already thought Hassan was a or whatever.
Or I already thought Hassan miners, so I don't care about this.
It's like small compared. I think that's Lav's thoughts. Polloju
sends another log here. Another another time stamp.
It's 36 minutes this time. 36 M should get me the time stamp.
>> YouTuber who warps c. >> Okay, let's see. news
and true crime to >> Oh, it's another big yawn.
This is where we were hoping. >> Primarily transphobic
and anti-semitic. She also denies the says the realh.
What did I do? I full screen. >> Ethnic cleansing
>> German. She's a grifter. Yeah, it's funny to see like
a black woman do the whole like the bolsheviks did the real Yeah,
it's funny. She also said the real ethnic cleansing.
>> So, we're looking below. I think we're looking like
here, right? So, again, I would wonder why. I believe we've looked
over this one, right? Is this the 2hour? Yeah, we've looked through
a bunch of these. This is another one where I personally feel
like the fur would be sticking out more in the way it is for
the Air Tag, right?
>> So, we'll we'll go through we'll look through. We would
we would expect Okay. What we would expect here for this picture,
okay, we can see the Air Tag is clearly pushing the hair outwards.
Yes.
We can see the hair is being pushed outwards by the tag protruding
on the sides of the collar. We cannot see the similar thing happening
down where we'd expect the e-collar to be. Okay.
In the way that we see in some of the other clips in the way
we see here, right in this clip you've ever appeared. >> Wait,
is this the one >> reactionary content I've dunked on before?
He's just like too stupid to >> There was a never mind.
I forget where here we we had Ka moving. I had a time stamp from
this vaude. I've moved way past it though. Whoops. Oh, this is
right here. Okay, hold on. 1 hour 4542.
>> Even this guy who is like a relatively
industry coherent argument
here
>> I've I've dunked on before. He's just like too stupid
to make
Oh, this is back. I should I should kill more tabs. But what's
also >> I should kill more tabs more often. God damn it.
No, we're we're moving away from this. Either way, on this day,
we've got an actual shot of Kaia getting up and having the the
thing on. This is the next day because she's got the actual e-collar
on. Let me see where you're at properly because it gets so good.
What are you talking about, Maximus? Oh, you're talking about
house. Jesus, you're throwing me off talking about other chat.
That's my bad, man.
where are we at? We're We're going back to this VOD. Going back
to look.
Okay, so we're an hour and 30 through this. I'm going to take
another screenshot of this time stamp.
Go through here.
Actually should take this time stamp as
Name VOD. Close this
to start cleaning up tabs. Things I don't need need this still.
We don't need this anymore.
This would be nice just to show
>> this would be nice just to show really quickly
when she's wearing the next
engaging in anti
demonstrations. So, when she's wearing the actual e-collar, do
you see how it still protrudes in the same way the Air Tag does?
There's still a clear protruding
of the e-collar.
All right. That you can't really get away from this thing sticking
out. It is just too big. It's just too big. What's the verdict?
Uh, the verdict is inconclusive. We cannot find any conclusive
evidence whatsoever of the e-collar existing in this uh in this
VOD >> for seven. I think we've ruled out that it could
be on top of Hassan's uh on top of Kaia's head. It would have
to be here in this gap and we don't see solid evidence that it's
there. We see nothing opening up to show the e-collar
>> 70
though, right? Hassan is horrible.
>> Then you are basically once again creating a permission
structure for Israel's violence. Reaffirm the need. >> Did
I just move away by a mission >> and simultaneously
um lying by a mission? Anyway, let's hear what
I feel like we're about to get on here. There we go. >> Better
statement looks like for two years we have witnesses
though perpetuates more for the children so many lives apart
more violence. We all have the courage to end decades of violence
and
>> okay we're going to look for another big move here
>> another big place. Oh, Kai getting up. Kai getting frisky.
Looking around, >> especially in the aftermath of 2 years
has taken.
>> So, she gets up here. It's taking place. Wait, is that
the one where um where Dan thought that Hassan was trying to
convince Ka to
to like go back to place by saying has taken place >> of
apartheid,
especially in the aftermath of 2 years of genocide that has taken
place. To me, >> was that was that supposed to be Hassan
trying to covertly do a place command right there.
>> Comes across as utterly ridiculous. >> Do we see
Okay, we're looking one more time. I was even looking at the
caller each of these times cuz we don't really see it. Unfort
me it comes across
>> we see something here >> of genocide that has
taken place. >> What is this?
>> Do we see something protruding out here?
>> Hold on. When she leans she kind of
to me. >> Am I seeing something? Am I
>> Oh, that's just literally the fold of her like neck
fat meeting her shoulder. That's not even where her collar would
be. Whoops. Whoops.
>> Unlucky. as utterly ridiculous and I think a lot of
people
>> yeah okay >> I don't think you always have to
talk about it within >> man I I find this very interesting
that we have not found anything close to definitive yet
and trust me once this is done it's going to be done guys once
we don't find anything here all right the best thing about the
drama is that you don't need to listen this drama is you don't
need to listen to his words ah >> Zionist care about >> that's
that's where it gets complexable
contend with his words. >> The very fact that your name
is Zoranqame
Mamani and that you are a Muslim anti-Zionist.
>> Uh so Asia, just I I know you're a big you're like,
"Oh, this guy's lost it cuz he's sweeping for Assassan." I see
your comments on the YouTube videos. I don't think you could
substantiate this at all. But I'm going to be I'm going to be
kind in this case and sort of explain this to you. Okay. Assan
has multiple collars. He said he had multiple callers right from
the beginning. He does have an e-collar. When he pulled off the
caller to show XQC, XQC was analyzing this clip where we see
the green light beeping, right?
So, in order to respond to this, he shows this clip and shows
what it is, right? He then says, "Yesterday,
uh, yesterday he says something along the lines of it wasn't
even the E color that was on her. It's literally a color without
the the E- color on it at all. That's what it is." Yes. Pretty
sure the most important point is that Hassan is bad. Well,
I just like being accurate. Okay,
that's all. Just like being accurate,
so we are looking for below the air tag for there to be this
box here. This is We've seen this formation in multiple different
VODs that are not the VOD where where Kai was puredly shocked
that it is buckle,
air collar,
box. And this box seems to be sticking out every single time
it's on the collar. In the case of this bot, it seems like very
clearly maybe the box got displaced. Maybe the collar has been
shifted in some way that makes it very confusing that isn't commensurate
with any of the other times it's been seen. But that box doesn't
appear to be there on the collar. We have seen no evidence of
it
And because we see no evidence of this box, I think Hassan has
some merit.
But then on the other side of that, you'd have to you would have
to assume that perhaps Hassan or one of his people went through
this VOD, the VOD from October 7th, and thought, "Oh, well, you
can't see the e-collar. You should just say you didn't have the
e-collar on at all." That's possible.
But I'm looking through and just trying to see if we can find
any proof either way on whether or not the e-collar is there
because he's now said conclusively the e-collar wasn't on it.
And
hey, I just I like looking into stuff. All right. Oh, hold on.
I'm getting timestamps from somebody. like that. >> Uh,
let's listen to this. This is on October 9th. >> I have
multiple I have multiple collars. I'm going to address the collar
thing in a second as well, but I have multiple collars for Gaia
and uh I put an air tag on them.
I put an air tag on all of her uh collars to make sure. >> So,
there's an air tag on each one of these collars. The problem
I have is that you like being accurate about Hassan specifically
while you go hard on Asthmold. Asmin Gold is a total degenerate,
wretched excuse for a human being that if you look up to, just
leave now. Okay.
Asmin Gold is fundamentally like the the ABS. Well, hold on.
I should say with regards to politics, in personal relationships,
he seems like he could be a nice person. Okay. With regards to
politics, I have so much larger an issue with Asmin Gold's project
than Hassan's. It's difficult to describe. Okay. It's like the
sun to like an atom. Okay. Okay. The problems I have with Asminold's
political project and the way he uses populism versus what Hassan
does. All right.
No, it's not even close. Asian Mock Asminold supports the downfall
of your country, the shredding of your constitution. You have
to understand that Hassan saying that well to stop a genocide
if some people got to get kidnapped. That's a stupid statement,
but it is not anywhere anywhere near as disgusting as the things
Asminold says and routinely supports, right? But he doesn't even
do it. Hassan is taking the worst instance, the worst description
of the bad thing. Hey, you're supporting kidnappers. You're supporting
people who have kidnapped civilians in order to support their
goals. He takes the worst instance and he supports that and he
says it 10 toes down. He is directly transparent with what his
positions are. Asmin Gold rarely contends with the actual like
negative uh what would you call it? Like the knockon effects
of his positions at all. He just says, "Well, yeah, I I'd like
to go to the border and and catch some people in a Pokemon outfit.
Got to catch a ball, guys. Got to catch a ball.
At least Assan contends with the the actual like effects of the
positions he holds. Anyway, so that's that's the difference.
Okay. Asmagold is a Asmigold as a streamer seems very entertaining
and I think he's a lot more intelligent than most other propagandists,
but I think Hassan's willing to look at the negative downsides
of the things he says, and I've at least seen him go, "Yeah,
I do still support that." So anyway, that would be why I have
a lot more issue with with Asminold, right? The things he supports
just broadly Trump support in general is is disgusting to me.
It's completely offputting. If you can't see the trend that that's
you can't see the direction that's going in, then you don't des
you don't deserve your voice, okay? In a lot of ways.
Even any intelligent Trump supporter right now is like soft distancing.
They can see that this is a total disaster, right? You see every
person within one any modum of intelligence distancing over time.
And I think Asmin Gold's filled a void there. And I think Asmin
Gold's making a lot of money right now. Yeah, Asia Mock, you're
lost. You're completely lost.
You're like entirely lost on this. Um, and that's why I guess
there are a lot of people like you who are lost in a very similar
way who can't see the harm of like Asmin Gold's political project
versus Hassan's. You can't see it at all. You are blinded. Right,
Hassan? How many people that Hassan even tangentially supports
have any amount of power? You're like the kind of person who
would say, "Well, Charlie Kirk, he just debated high school guys
or college kids. Why would why would anybody think he's a political
person? He just debates high school kids. Sorry, college kids."
Like the same thing. Yeah. It's Oh, it's it's actually tragic.
It's very tragic to me that you that you operate this way, that
you would want your country like taken down in this way. But
um if you want to say that supporting Trump is not really like
a a problem for you or you think that's a good solution politically
or if anybody supporting Trump is like somehow comparable to
Hassan basically advocating for democratic socialism, a move
towards socialism over time, which is all I've ever seen him
advocate in any serious political sense for. Right? If you want
to compare those two and say they're similar, I think you are
a reprehensible
I think you are reprehensible just in general. But
that's fine. You can do that. Lots of lots of people in America
not not even really making that much of a difference. I'm telling
you that if you support Asmin Gold as he is obviously the most
effective Trump supporter that is like doing propaganda like
proTrump propaganda who who never ever can see like the downsides
of the things Trump's doing. If you want to if you want to say
that that's fine and that's comparable to, you know, being neutral
on Hassan, me being hard on Asthmold for the the positions, right,
for supporting Trump is the same as me not wanting to go hard
on Hassan for being a dog abuser.
That's that's insane. But it's fine. Again, I don't even really
feel the need to talk about it anymore.
>> I have multiple collars for Kaya and uh I put an air
tag on them. So, multiple >> I put an air tag on all of
her collars to make sure that, you know, I know where she's at.
>> And one of the collars that people are pointing to in
the uh from previous days or from like months ago
is the collar that is a vibration collar. A collar that I use
specifically to
a collar that I use specifically to communicate with. Yeah, I
see him talking about how she was wearing it on previous days.
So it it seems like
right when he says the color she's been wearing on previous days,
it seems like he's saying there by omission, not on this day.
Ka when she's free roaming at the park or when she is, you know,
uh off leash running around. Okay? Because when you when you
leave your dog to free roam
to go out on the trail or whatever, there are going to be instances
where you can yell for her to come back to do recall, but because
she's so far away that she can't hear you. Okay, that's Yeah,
we heard all of this. So, he's saying that this caller from previous
days. Interesting. Okay. Uh, what if you were my kaya but Okay,
stop. Gross. Gross. Uh, that's actually a timeout for you. Gross.
Take an hour off, buddy. Take an hour off, buddy. You're disgusting.
Shut up.
Okay. All right. So, this is basically him saying these colors
from previous days. Now, I wonder if he has like figured out
at this point, this is 2 days after or something, that she wasn't
wearing that collar that day. I do >> That's where the
vibration collar comes >> Oh, sorry. This is one day later.
This is the next day. >> It vibrates. It doesn't actually
have any sort of like shocking component.
Okay. And there are multiple different versions of this.
Um, there are the noar collars that I believe both vibrate and
also emit like a large sound, like a loud sound. There are shock
collars as well. They all look very similar to one another.
Okay.
But the vibration collar is what what they were pointing to.
Okay. To be like, "Oh my god, he has a he has a collar that he's
uh using to abuse her and shocking her." There are a lot of dogs
who use this.
Okay. There are also a lot of dogs, working dogs that use a shock
collar as well. Me see here that day maybe. Okay. I'm looking
for like anything I could maybe uh track over to
I understand for those of you who are confused by it. Uh I do
not have a shock collar for Kaya as I said yesterday, but it
doesn't matter. People don't give a [__] And all
of the uh other
all of the other clips that people uh have been showing are either
the air tag or the Okay, I'm just looking for anything else that
we could go to the uh
previous days
like a day in the life of Ka every single day.
I'm just I'm looking for anything that like I could see where
he's pointing out because he says previous days as in not on
that day, but I'm looking for any stronger statement here because
it would be nice if he had a stronger statement back earlier,
right? I just feel like it would work a lot more in his favor
if we're we're trying to say like, well, could he be exonerated
in some way if that was what you were trying to do? Like a statement
from earlier would be helpful. This one is kind of tough. We're
just scrolling through here shots under the >> unacceptable
for them.
So, you know, you have Okay, hold on.
We got We get more movement, guys. More movement. >> Wait,
who who is this for? >> Now, hold on. Oh, we see the
There's another look. We're getting another look here. Copy video
URL time. So, this is going to be another look. I'm going to
save this really quickly.
Caller views right there. Okay,
now
we see this circular piece here with the air tag. >> I
will just be your pay. Uh, I don't see >> Ruben donated
very much Ruben. Appreciate it, buddy. >> Stream all his
kay content on Rumble.
Stop. Stop. Stop. Okay. >> Wait. Who is this for? >> My
bad for the spam. No, you're fine. You're fine. And I guess maybe
it's for uh the the squishy liberals who obviously want
>> somewhere after this we get
statements such as this one >> are not actually going to
>> we're almost done with the first VOD >> are not
actually going to win him favors with a lot of people >> cuz
the pro genocide people are still going to call him a terrorist
today. They're going to call him a terrorist tomorrow and they're
going to try to continue to do everything they can to >> is
not moving around to make sure that he doesn't win the election.
>> Looking looking.
>> My point is
after two years of genocide
after two years him because he has spent uh many many years.
>> See again if we didn't have that other screenshot showing
that this is clearly fur. I feel like on top is where you looked
right is where you would look.
Like this could look bad. It looked bad to me in a few other
screenshots, but then we saw the screenshot showing clearly that
this is just like a patch of dark colored fur that's being pushed
that is the reason why I allow it in this in this moment is is
>> like I said um mentions of October 7 without talking
about like what led to O >> are we not going to get any
KA movement before the end of the stream? Oh,
>> dead stream in a second.
>> No Ka movement at all. Okay, so first VOD, we've seen
no indication that I've seen yet of the actual caller. Okay,
we're moving on to the second VOD once he comes back. I believe
it's 3 minutes into this VOD when he does, you know, when we
believe he could have shocked
So, we'll take a look. >> See me? Oh, great. Predictably
of >> So, he's clearly very >> because I'm in there.
She is scratching. >> United States.
>> She scratches.
>> Scratches could get ships in the collar. >> dog
[__] country on the [__] planet. >> The
absolute worst country on the planet. Straight up. Bar none.
A
>> Whoa. She's on the move.
>> Oh man. Is her hair caught there? That's very interesting,
isn't it?
He changed colors when the stream went down. No, he didn't change
colors when the stream went down. Um, we would still expect the
box to be somewhere below the air tag
>> That was not the opportunity for you to
down the absolute worst place on the planet. Just a horrific
monstrous >> piece of [__] >> Awful forcing
play there all day. >> Country that I despise.
The absolute worst country that has the most the most
>> poor kaya poor kaya poraya d colon
>> wealth throughout history throughout >> they're
all they're all already upset >> the wealthiest nation
on the planet and we don't have a fraction of >> she looks
sad I wouldn't doubt right here by the way guys I wouldn't doubt
that she can tell that he's irritated about his stream going
down and she's like uncomfortable being there cuz he is not just
like calm or doing whatever. He's probably like actually quite
irritated. You can probably hear that in his voice, right? Like
dogs are not um like they don't have complex thoughts, but I
feel like they can tell when you're like irritated, when you're
upset, right? You'll see a dog go to the other side of the room
if you're like really angry about something, right? They can
just tell. They they pick up like the body language. >> The
dedicated broadband speeds that you can get in a village on the
countryside of France.
Okay. I just the worst [__] infrastructure the absolute
biggest on the planet. I
this country with my entire [__] >> It just
sucks so bad. Every time I guess I should say >> I can
and I can getiest.
>> And this is okay.
>> But it is embleatic of all of America's much more consequential
>> but it is emblematic of all of America's much more con
>> man. I can't get over this top part. It still looks
like that. Like that's probably your best bet if you think cuz
really you'd expect it to be sitting out here a little bit >> on
this side. You'd expect to be able to see something poking out
here. >> Violence.
Okay. It's the same reason as to why America ka please. >> She's
making her break for it. She's making her break for it. I think
you can see pretty clearly there's not another thing sticking
out past this. He's so
>> man. I just see the air tag piece and I think you see
pretty easily there that that's just like hair on the top too.
Like that that black piece on the top is not connected to the
collar, right? You see it pretty openly right here. We'll copy
this at current time. Okay. Yeah, this is well this is like the
collar and then you can see that this is hair separating this
black piece. This is like something to do with her. I don't know
if it's an undercoat. I don't know what's going on there. Okay.
Go. Would you stop? >> There it is. There it is.
Now she jumps. >> Reason as to why America ka please
>> What is that hand doing?
>> Jesus Christ. What are you doing? You're being such
a baby. It's just
>> So I will say on the side of believing that the shock
occurs here. Okay. On that side, if you're the people who believe
the shock occurs here. All
I'd say this is your best argument.
If the dog just yelped randomly and he has no idea why, no matter
how annoyed he is, he probably goes, "You know what? I should
go over there." I feel like him knowing
what precisely happened, like precisely what happened to her
would be his best rationale
for not walking over and checking on her in some way. I think
that is probably the best argument.
Uh, Stephen Jelly, you just come back tomorrow, buddy. Good luck.
I enjoy I enjoy doing this. If you don't enjoy doing this, that's
totally fine.
>> You're making her stressed. I I She just
>> So, we have um
where is he? Puluju says 2711 here. So, you think 2711 is the
is good shots of it on the next the next time she moves.
Palestinians that are kept under administrative detention to
be able to return to their families just as I want the apartheid
to end. >> Where are we at here? >> But do you see
>> 271? Okay. 2711. Ooh, we get a good look at the fact
that it's definitely not up top again.
>> Right. Good, good, good look.
>> And we see the fur is not even pushed out by it here
at all. There is nothing pushing fur here at all.
Hold on. Act 90. We are investigating a totally different theory
right now,
Yeah, this is probably fair. Geranium. Now, I will say Hassan,
I believe, apologizes near the end of this VOD and says, "I should
have gone and checked on her. I'm an I was frustrated cuz the
stream went down and I didn't care about her and I'm I'm a piece
of [__] for that." I think I think that's basically
what he says at the end. Now, boring dog doesn't move much. I
think at some point we're getting close to where she would leave
at this point as well. So, I'm seeing a lot of indications that
we don't have an e-collar on this day. Reasons to believe there
may not be an e-collar on this day at all. Now, will anybody
go through and look at this and and reckon with that fact at
all? That it's clearly not up top. It's clearly not below where
we would expect it to be or sorry, I won't say it's clearly not
below yet. We don't have like definitive evidence of it being
of it not being below, but we would expect the fur to be to be
displaced on the bottom in the same way. We're not seeing that
>> asymmetry there.
>> Oh, I feel like you're getting a way better look at
the Air Tag displacing the fur and no displacement past the Air
Tag. I think you're getting a really, really good look. Oh boy,
>> this is not hypocrisy. >> Oh man, that feels
like a really good look. >> This is an accurate reflection
of events. Oh,
>> is no longer a mod in this channel. That's not
>> I'm not seeing any displacement of fur around this at
all.
Right.
Am I >> the case? >> She's also turning away, stretching
that area, though. Yeah. She's literally opening up where you
would expect the hair to be.
Like, you can't tell me that there's so much more pressure right
here that it pushes the hair down, right?
as opposed to why does displacement matter? Because we expect
the box to be right here, derbanadium.
And we see how it displaces fur completely here in another VOD,
right? It displaces the fur completely in another VOD. Uh we
we expect the buckle airteag e-collar aspect to hold up. We're
not seeing any displacement of the fur here.
We're not seeing it. That that would be the hypothesis, Private
Puff. That would be the hypothesis.
It's all the neck fat that's making it hard to see in multiple
different angles where you can clearly see the air tag, but you
can't see this.
Even though there are no other examples of that, we have two
other examples where that's not the case.
Right? We can see it clearly showing here where it's in a very
similar
Right? On this day, it's showing very clearly. Bro, you know,
he got neck meat. I listen, I'm taking a very I I'm taking an
objective look at this, okay? If you guys want to, again, I'm
totally down. You want to make an actual point, you want to make
an argument, the Discord is discord.gg/jstylk,
I'm just operating off of tangible evidence, okay? There's no
way he showed. So he said pragu if you listen to him he says
he's showing one of multiple colors and he is explicitly when
he talks about this day talks about the multiple colors he references
the collar from this day and says that's a different color that
just rumbles and then she happens to be wearing that collar that
day. He takes that collar off and shows it. Oh, Dingolingus has
moved on to the next stage. Okay, he's going through the five
stages of copium dying. Okay, he's moved on to negotiation.
All right. He's trying to negotiate. Um, even if even if it was
there, you just say it doesn't prove it could shock. No, I one,
we don't have proof they can shock, but I'm willing to admit
that they they could shock. In fact, on day one, I said I think
this is most likely a shock capable model.
uh so cold brew yes I agree with you that he has a shock capable
collar but we are going through the vaude of the day and we are
showing that there is no evidence that she is wearing the e-collar
on that day.
That's what we're showing here right now. If the dog is not wearing
the e-collar
what was she getting shocked by? Yeah, I I I'll tell you when
Hassan said this, I was like, "Oh, that's going to give people
We'll come back in a day and we'll see if anybody's gone through
the VOD and seen if they could show it wearing the e-collar."
Cuz as soon as you show it wearing the e-collar on that day,
Hassan is now conclusively lying and conclusively proven like
totally like he obviously would have shocked the dog. He's actually
totally Maybe Hassan is actually Raiden. Maybe maybe that's why
Hassan's gotten so mad. He didn't really get mad about being
accused of using an e-collar. Perhaps his anger stem from his
the exposure of him as a god of lightning, a god of thunder.
Okay. And that is what he's actually upset about. So he even
shows people, he even goes back and shows them a collar that
could shock. Tries to get himself caught and goes, "God damn
it. Why don't they just accept that I shocked the dog with an
e-collar? Why are they trying to prove that I have powers?"
Yeah, sure. Sure. Well, I could see it. I could see it. Okay,
so we still we've still not seen it. We've gone through all of
these clips. We've gone through a lot of footage here trying
to see exactly where
under that theory. Why does he reach off screen? Well, hold on.
You're you're asking me literally we can see the This is like
us being able to see directly directly that there's no way to
shock Ka and you're going why does he reach off screen then?
I don't know, bro.
You understand that your thinking is totally shaped by how this
situation was presented to you, right?
I don't have any idea why he reaches off screen there. I don't
have any idea what he's reaching for. Maybe he wants to say,
"Ka, go back." Maybe he's trying to mute his mic. I don't know.
I'm not even trying to hypothesize. I don't have an indication.
I don't know why people are still invested in this drama. Well,
so Canon 137,
I'm only invested in it because it seems like if you were on
the side of Hassan definitely shocked his dog, there's a way
to go through this VOD and prove that it could have happened,
right? And now I'm I'm interested because people are so invested
in this and that nobody's gone through and found the clip that
from this VOD that shows that the box is on the collar, the e-collar
box is on the collar. Well, that seems like people might have
might have gone through it and realized there's nothing there
and now they're trying to find different ways to freak out about
this. Denying the shot caller is like Holocaust denial. It's
almost I'm getting the impression that we're uh we're moving
in that direction. Wait, I'm sorry. What is an e-collar? An e-collar
is the actual type of collar, cold brew, that Kaia was wearing
um on the next day and previously in the VOD. I'm not convinced
either way. I'd like to see the neck underside.
So, I would like to see that too, Bub Rob. But I I'm
telling you that I I if you could show me a clip of her wearing
the e-collar where it obfiscates to this degree at all, then
maybe. But I when I can see the air tag that clearly, I don't
know what situation you could have where you would have none
of the collar or none of the fur being displaced here, right?
Like the fur would have to be more displaced somehow to to accommodate
something this size, but it is not.
Like, do you do you disagree with that?
You're expecting the E- module to be right next to it. I'm expecting
the E- module to be exactly where it is in every other instance.
Yes.
If not there, then I would expect it to be shown somewhere else
in the color,
36 minutes. There are some shots, too.
>> Unless she personally >> So, hold on. We should
stay zoomed in here some else going on here. >> So, like
there maybe you got something >> Unless she personally
unmodied
>> like No, I don't. Dude, I don't see [__]
there. I don't.
>> Um, she is still a mod. And >> hold on. I should
go uh I should go make sure I grab this time stamp as well and
put that in the list.
Uh day two
or sorry should go VOD 2. All >> Monitor herself.
>> Um look at all that neck neck fat. Well, so it's neck
fat and it is um it's it's hair, right? Like you could see its
hair cuz you could see how deep the trenches are to go through
the hair to actually tighten the collar, right?
Okay. Holy X Grail, I will accept. No more
no more weight shaming for Ka. Okay, that's insane. What are
you doing, bro? What are you doing? What do you think you're
doing? The dog has to be wearing either the vibrator or shock
collar because at the beginning of the clip, he vibrates/shocks
the dog before the yelping clip. Okay, show me where that is.
Gif Hegel 69. Go ahead, link me where that happens so we can
go through and find it.
I've not seen that. I believe you're probably talking about this
clip where it clearly shows the e-collar, but if you're not,
then I would I'd love to go see
love to go see it. Okay.
Anyway, so 36 minutes is what our good friend Pugoloju
says is the next time stamp. So, let's let's take a look. Is
this Ka moving her head around or is that >> dollars to
take over? >> Oh, she's moving her head around a little
bit. 202 the country's >> okay
so 36 minutes about is where we get our next bit of ka movements
where we can see the collar okay >> I don't know what the
if you can't compro if you can't see that America is currently
in the process collapse
>> so again >> we've seen basically goes down >> almost
confirmation that this is just hair here right >> time
the craziest chatter start >> did he even put his in his
mouth I don't know if he put his in his mouth I kind of doubt
What would be interesting is I guess we have to go through this
VOD and see if he has any Zins on that side of the uh of the
VOD, right?
At 18 minutes exactly on the first VOD on YouTube. Okay. Well,
you know what? Let's go check it out. Apparently, the dog is
shocked at 18 minutes on the first VOD on YouTube.
>> So, this is where we see the dog get >> Commemorative
mug I got from >> Oh, hold on. >> from England. Commemorative
mug I got from England specifically. You think You think that's
him shocking the dog right there? You think You think he shocks
the dog here? Vibrated or shocked?
Why? Because he's reaching over to that side of his desk where
his soundboard
>> Commemorative mug I got from England specifically for
uh for when I was there when he was getting
>> specific. I understand that he's leaning over here,
but you do know like his stream deck is also right there, right?
You do know that like if he's doing anything with regards to
the stream.
>> Commemorative mug I got from England. Commemorative
mug I got from England. >> I mean, if you're if you're
on the side of she definitely got shocked, then I could see why
you would think that that is him shocking her, right? He stops
talking as if he's focused on something else. She seems to move
uh more aggressively than she moves at other times. I'm trying
to differentiate between what is color here and what isn't. We
see anything. I wish I saw something more there. Yeah, I'm playing
a video. Yeah, I just can't see her laying down on the bed that
he shocks her there. I don't but
uh I just I don't necessarily see it. >> I do find it like
weird that he is like not thinking as he goes to do something.
>> Jaws the 3rd, September 8th, 2022. >> We go back
see what he's talking about. >> A commemorative mug I got
from a >> So, how long here would be here would be a good
question. Okay, here would be a very very good question.
4632 in 46 or 4236 in VOD chose it. Which VOD? Lowi?
Which VOD? Okay. Um, first one or second one. And we'll we'll
take a look. Sorry. I'm trying to see how long was Kaia laying
exactly like this for.
So he looks
Hold on. Let's take a look. He looks over at Kaa. >> Man,
only two viewers falling off. You already know.
>> So he looks over at Kaa.
Ka is laying in that position for like five minutes before he
possibly shocks
>> So
I I don't know.
The dog never moves until he reaches off screen and does something.
Uh reaches off screen. Like he reaches over. Yes. But like why
would he reach over? Why would he wait five minutes to reach
over >> on the Fox News? >> Let's go. Let's enter
the mind. Okay. We're going to we're going to we're going to
skinwalk Hutch for like 5 minutes. As we watch this, we're going
to look to build the narrative that Hassan is slowly filling
with rage as he notices that actually off camera, Kaia has just
one paw slightly off the bed. Okay. And so he's looked over once,
he's noticed, and by 18 minutes, we're at 1350. By 18 minutes,
he's built up the rage to shock his dog just for
just for having one tiny toe, one claw touching the ground.
Okay, so we'll look.
We'll look. Remember that I believe his kaya stuff is to his
right. His kayak cam, I believe, is to his right. That's why
he looks right and reaches left.
>> That's crazy. I can't believe he did this.
He's just trying not to get >> guest. Looks like Jesse
Waters >> kicked out of the country. I'll try to speed
up a little bit. Okay. >> And now he's like betraying me.
I see >> he looks he looks over to his right. And now I
expect him to while seething filled with rage look to his right
to see is Ka really doing this. She thinks just because I can't
see it on the camera. I can't see her sign of defiance hanging
this one paw off of the screen.
Uh can you see the red blinking signal from the e-collar? I don't
think you do. No. Oh, also Lui, don't forget to relink me the
the time stamp that you wanted to. Um, I'm I'm looking at this.
We'll look at this real quick and then I'll switch over to yours.
Okay. >> Um, in any case, ladies and gentlemen, boys, girls,
and MBs, we are live. We're alive. Uh, personal news-wise, I
ended the broadcast last night cuz I felt really tired.
But um I also wanted to spend some time with my family and that's
precisely what I did with Morat,
with Morat's wife,
uh with my mom.
We hung out. Uh they ordered dinner. I was supposed to not eat
for the next 20. I was supposed to do a big fast for like 24
hours, maybe 30 or a little bit longer, maybe like 48 hour fast
>> to just try to do like a detox. >> So he's already
aware Hassan's in this position, right? from all the all the
[__] that I ate. You know what I mean?
But uh they ordered they ordered uh
Damn. Uncle Nick, did you think about producing that for content?
We could watch your uncle be like, "Yeah, I think you watch without
sound and try to figure out where he was shocking her and your
uncle picked it out perfectly each time." That's crazy. >> Some
some chicken katsu. So, I broke that. And I will tell you something,
okay? Obviously, it's fine. I didn't eat that much and I had
like a little bit of a protein shake and whatnot, I had a little
taste of chicken katsu. It's all good. But it's important to
recognize that even a couple crackers and like one chicken katsu,
like one piece of chicken c this is Hassan lamenting his lack
of discipline on the same day his lack of discipline leads to
the shocking
I just did it. God damn it. War crime committed against Kaio.
Okay, >> disgusting. It adds up
>> cuz I looked at I logged everything cuz I was like I
ate a couple things couple finger without even thinking about
it and then I logged >> Ka moves very slightly very slight
breathe in and out there that could that could cause him to get
angry >> to see where I was at like to see how many calories
I consumed and in your mind you're thinking like I got to be
like 300 it was like 1,100
Uh, then I would say you probably didn't have just a bite of
chicken katsu and a couple crackers, buddy. >> Just off
the rip for no reason. Just like with finger foods.
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> So, in any case, um,
>> don't log your food. Come from recovering fat girl.
Well, from a recovering fat girl. From one recovering fat girl
to the next, uh, logging your food has been very helpful for
me.
>> Oh god. Do not show Amaranth this vod. Okay. Do not
show this to Nick or Amaranth. Nick Nick Wick Lee absolutely
just scrolling down the time stamp for this right now. He's like,
I'm I'm going to show this to Kate. It'll convince her once and
for all. You have to track >> Bro, your diet hasn't been
fixed for like 3 months. Lock in already. No, I know. I haven't
been able to lock in at all. It's been locking out. I've been
locking out. It's been pretty hard to
to keep up with everything. Um, what is this? Good video covering
the current Venezuela situation from Preston Stewart. So, I haven't
seen this guy like super [__] pro American gung-ho
military guy. Nat, >> I've not even seen him really acknowledge
or look at Ka's like presence. Okay, >> that guy. He's
like a natse tik tocker. Um, but I'll I'll take a look at it.
>> Oh, there's a little hiccup there. >> So,
moves her head slightly.
I will be locking in though. Don't worry. Do not worry. I will
be locking in. Uh, >> I'll be locking in spectac style.
Okay, I am already locked in. Let's be real. I'm already locked
in. I'm locked in and uh not locked out. So, uh I went to bed
at 9,
went to sleep. >> Uh if you if you are unaware right now,
>> pig a donation from that. >> Donated $3. Ham should
probably think about getting her another cage and lock it with
a bolt.
>> Uh god damn it, Reuben. Ruben. So,
so we'll continue. I do not think he could do that without adjusting
the
Would you not have to adjust the remote here,
Giggle?
In any case. Okay. In any case,
I'm watching. I have not seen her move. She's been hanging out
like this and he hasn't shocked her yet. We are tminus
60 seconds from the shock. The purported shock. Okay. Uh went
to sleep by 10:00, woke up at 4:00, watched a little bit of co
pass back out, woke up at 7,
and then I uh went and I baldled.
I went and I baldled my freaking face off.
>> And his face off. >> Now he looks over. Now he's
going to see Ka. Okay. A little bit before. Let me slow it back
down. >> I'm not as my cardio is
because you know you put a couple pounds >> Makes it more
difficult to move around fast. But also on top of that, uh, you're
just when you don't like consistently ball and you go back to
it for a week, if you don't do like a lot of exercise for a week,
it's just crazy. >> I would agree with you that she moves
quickly in this clip.
>> Who's on the cup? The king to commemorate the ascension
to the throne of his majesty, King Charles III. >> Okay,
now I'll tell you what I'm doing right now. Okay, I'm actually
looking at the chat. I'm looking for somebody to go, "Ka looks
so sad." And for Han to react to that reading that chat message
of Ka looks so sad right now with, "Oh, I'm going to shock you,
Ka." >> September 8th, 2022. >> I don't see anything
about Ka yet. The chat is good and locked onto him. >> A
commemorative mug I got from England. Commemorative mug I got
from England specifically
for uh for when I was
I just don't I just don't see I don't see it, man. I don't look
I tried I tried, man. I tried to build it for you.
I can't even
I I can't even think
I can't even think of like what set that off. Ka literally sits
there in the same spot for like five minutes and then you think
he just decides he's going to shock her.
>> Mug I got from England. Commemorative mug I got from
England. Like I I could see how if you basically decided this
had happened that this is what makes you think. Yeah. Okay. Now
I need to go open Wowi's message here. Give me a second. Give
me a second. >> But due to this time stamp for us on the
first thing and he says you could see the caller at this time
stamp
>> So let's take a look. Take a look. >> As Ben Shapiro
has very openly stated and I did not see it there, but maybe
we're looking at the Daily Wire. She got fired from the Daily
Wire. Not due to her aunties. It'll be where we move.
>> so you do not see down on the bottom the collar at all
here. There is no there is nothing on the bottom at all. Um in
fact, Lui, I think the only reason or the only way that you could
think that the box is there is if you think the air tag is the
e-collar.
This one's pretty much near conclusively a no. Not conclusively
but near conclusively a no. You see the air tag here which is
not the box. Right. So again we look at a very good view here.
We see the box the the e-collar box and then the air tag here.
>> So all the >> right this is the view from the
side. This box pushes out both horizontally and ver I guess both
you know in terms of depth towards us and yeah like in terms
of breadth across the collar. It sticks out more than the air
tag does it seems like. No worries. No worries. I Trust me, Lowi,
if you can find me, if anybody can go through this, do we check
36? We did. I thought 36 was pretty definitive. Like, no. Um,
and if you can find a picture that looks like it's there in one
of these VODs, we're just looking for the truth. Okay, we want
this We want this to end one way or the other. Color Gate needs
to end today.
And we cannot go another day of Color Gate. Okay, it is cutting
into me actually learning about the world. Me actually like going
and finding I still have not read my article about the CIA being
deployed in Venezuela. Okay, because I have to keep looking at
this dog collar every
day.
What rem what still remains unanswered? Oh, Kilo, I can't do
the bit again. Um I'm sure if you talk to anybody, they'll they'll
explain exactly what we're doing here. I can't I can't explain
it all >> This does is brief. Anyway,
we've kilo, we've basically gone and eliminated
every single side view of this caller in the first VOD. Hassan
says she's not wearing an e-collar on the day that collar gate
happened. We've gone through nearly every minute of VOD from
this day. Okay. And we do not see it. Oh, the collar doesn't
look completely black like the box. Sure, there's a slight color
difference. Yeah. I don't know if you'd see this when it's being
shadowed necessarily, but so we're we're just going through all
of all of Color Gate here. Do we do 36 minutes? This is this
is the 306 minute section. Poolju
tell you
>> all the 36 minute section. We're looking. We're watching.
>> Shame goes down one time and the craziest chatter start
pouring. >> We're saying it's not an e-collar. >> We're
saying that Hassan has an e-collar, but she is wearing a different
color on this day. And I know
I don't know. I don't know what's going on today. It's been It's
been worse than uh it was before for sure.
>> Maybe it's because like I didn't get to read chat that
much
when I was live. >> Oh, am I in the wrong VOD? This part
two. No, it should be 36 minutes on this VOD. Did I just totally
miss whatever we're looking for?
>> Say or >> maybe I just missed it entirely. Oh,
little bits. Thank you for the 14 months
If you can't compro if you can't see that America is currently
in the >> uh the dog does follow the word commands Uncle
Nick completely which would be maybe another reason you wouldn't
expect the shot caller to be something that's >> process
of collapse. I don't know what to tell you. >> I thought
she kind of leaned. I know. I know. I know what's going on. It's
been worse than it was before. For sure. Maybe because I need
to recharge
that I'm not getting we have like some No, we don't have a weird
intro. Oh, I don't know why this isn't working or not lining
up for Golu, >> but I think maybe because like I said October
7th, so we got like a bunch of >> Sorry, first VOD. Oh,
first VOD 36 cuz I I remember when you crime primarily transphobic
and anti-semitic narrative. She also did a black woman. Like
why doesn't anybody talk about that? >> Oh me. Is this
going to be Is this going to be now the one with the little Yeah,
he's got his own little stupid intro, doesn't he?
>> Oh no, this should be >> like, bro, you are literally
a black woman.
Like that is crazy. >> I'm not seeing this at 36 minutes
in either VOD now. I don't know what's going on.
Let's keep looking through this second bod in the meantime. Okay,
keep taking a look. We're going to look for Kai to move again.
Do we get movement here? Get a little movement. Okay,
I know you had it. You linked me like a time stamp before.
>> Evangelical Zionist. >> Hold on. Here we go. >> Evangelical
Christian Zionist. >> Israel is basically losing every
single group. disapprove of Israel's conduct on the yawn has
committed against the Palestinians. Prime Minister >> got
nothing on the yawn here.
>> Got absolutely nothing on the yawn. Oh, we got movement
there and I moved too quickly. Hold on. We got movement.
>> Hold on.
Did I see a little >> I feel like I'm watching a totally
different news broadcast and not morning
>> Oh, maybe not. Nope.
I think I got fooled by this little pocket on her chest here
as it was moving along. Yeah, I got fooled. I got fooled. Look,
I'm trying I'm trying to look for you guys, okay? I'm trying
to make sure that I don't this up. We got nothing on the top
side either. Whoa, we got a little We got a little look here.
yeah. I still see the fur coming down over this even when she's
leaning down. Like, why would the fur be covering this when it
pushes out on the air tag? Even when she's looking down,
right? Even when she's looking down, the fur is still being covered.
Sorry. The the what could be the box there is still being covered.
Is that maybe a better look? Can we see here? That might be if
you're if you're pro- e-collar being here. Is that your best
look? Hoping for an e-collar to be there. That might be your
best look.
I still don't see it. I still see the fur like pretty conclusively
over the collar right here, but I don't see the actual box there
at all.
Yeah, I don't see the box at all. Yeah, this is Jonathan Greenblat's
favorite >> Guys, if you like the investigation content,
okay, if you if you enjoy the content, if you like the content,
go ahead, give me a follow on Twitch, give me a follow on Kick,
uh join or follow me on Twitter, join the Discord,
And if you really like the content, you can go ahead and donate
a couple subs. Add more time onto the stream. Every dollar donated
from subs, donations, bits, kicks, everything goes towards more
times on the stream. Okay? If you would like to buy a TTS message,
exclamation point donate in the chat will give you the links
to buy a TTS message. Okay, there's Kickbot. There's Streamlabs.
You can do it either way. Thank you very much. Get your message
right on stream. All right. Thank you guys. Thank you. Thank
you. Appreciate all the support. All right. Now, let's keep going.
Let's keep looking. Can we get a verdict? We actually look obsessed.
Uh, Black Ice.
I don't know why you would think that. We're trying to be We
are literally just trying to be
You can't call me I'm I'm literally trying to show that there
isn't an angle on this where you can even argue really that the
e-collar is there or I'm looking you know technically that's
what we have been doing and now I'm I'm sort of that's what my
belief is based on what we've seen when I started I just wanted
to take a look at what if there was an e-collar on here right
cuz if you could show an e-collar here then Hassan is conclusively
lying at that point but up until this point it seems like when
he says there is no e-collar
He might be telling the truth.
So, we get a poll to see where chat is at. Yeah, we can. Let's
go. Let's do a Let's get a poll.
Let's do a poll. Um, okay. We'll do 90 seconds. This is only
going to be on kick, guys. Sorry to the Twitchers. This is only
on the kick stream. Okay, we got a poll up now in the chat.
>> How'd this happen? Why is the stream offline? It's not.
>> We're looking for more Ka move. I've always said that
if you're against Israel's policy means you must be anti-semitic.
Well, in this case, I mean, the numbers are just staggering.
>> and if we were to take this premise at face value a
she wasn't like a mauide
his very obviousations, his racism, the fact that he was arrested.
>> Uh, no. Still inconclusive option. I guess not voting
would be the still inconclusive option. Just put three in the
chat if it's inconclusive. Okay. >> His ties to the socialist
group storm.
>> I I would say it's like I'm not even asking inconclu
I'm not asking for your conclusion here, Bub Rub. I'm saying
where where's your intuition on this? I'm just trying to find
intuition. That's really what it is. Uh cuz I would say it's
obviously inconclusive. We haven't gone through all the angles
yet, right? We haven't seen everything. So, obviously, you'd
have to say inconclusive, but I'm leaning towards no collar based
on what I've seen. >> On a day when unemployment is at
9.7%, this guy is tasked with bringing in more green jobs. And
>> yeah, Alan Alen Combmes is a great example of this who
just basically had to be the fake liberal on the Hannity and
Combmes broadcast for so long that it may or may not have given
him cancer that ended up he died by he died uh due >> Oh,
I just I just [__] up big time.
I just [__] up big time because I did not grab that
previous time stamp we were at. We were just looking at all the
stuff there.
>> Well, we're missing that time stamp for day two. God
damn it. >> He's not doing that. And
>> well, see, we're expecting her to stay down like this
for quite a while. She looks like she's actually gone to sleep
for Israel. >> I don't know what the going on. >> Okay,
she wakes up here. Hold on there. That might actually be
Jesus. Her face is like warped by being smooshed right now. It's
a very goofy look. Okay.
>> Success in speaking to try to see if we can see her
across all different parties.
You know, that was the center of US support for Israel for a
gener.
No, she just she just looks smooshed that whole time. >> Still
looks a shot on yet. Are people all right? Okay. Well, what are
you gonna do? >> Are people all right? >> Went right
at that. And uh so >> let's see if we could see her move,
but I think she's covered up. So
>> where where do we see the movement happen of her going
over? Right here.
>> Still votes overwhelmingly Democrat in the United States
of America as opposed to the Republican party
>> is also partially because like the one the issue of
Israel is not a partisan issue yet. I wish this was my job.
>> But two, they don't give a about Israel as much as they
care about other Democrats represent.
>> That's it. Because they're American. They're not Israeli.
They are in >> This is where she arrives at the smooshed
face
>> alarming rate. Chicago.
at an alarming rate >> at an alarming rate. >> The
other thing we're looking for here, guys, is basically any of
the if we see the light at all. If we see that green light on
where that box should be. If we see that even one iota, that's
it. That's ball game for Hassan. It's over.
>> Illinois aims to stop Trump from sending National Guard
troops to Chicago. >> Now, the latest >> uh I don't
know the real Dr. Cube. I have no reason to care or suspect anything
else right now. Right. That's the That's the issue is I don't
I don't need to be concerned at all about what possible reason
there was for her yelping. There's like a million different reasons,
right? We have no idea at all >> on President Trump's effort
to send National Guard troops to tackle crime in Democratic cities.
Demonstrators in Chicago accuse federal agents of using excessive
force, something the Trump administration denies. The state of
Illinois, meanwhile, >> is this what you wanted us on?
The majority of American people are now fiercely anti-Semitic.
I hope you're proud.
Yes.
Engage in shocking overreach. >> It follows mainly outside
of the ICE
>> shocking overreach. The only situations that are out
of control are certain ICE and Customs Border Patrol officers
who are engaged in shocking overreach. It >> a border patrol
officer who's engaged in shocking overreach. A a
interesting interesting
weeks of sweeping immigration raids in parts of Chicago
leading to at times intense protests mainly outside of the ICE
processing facility in the suburb of Broadview.
in recent days to protect suggest.
>> What is >> now? The Illinois federal judge overseeing
this case is expected to hear oral arguments on Thursday.
>> Is there like a LSF video or something? Is that why
there's like >> us out? Sure. I do that. >> Wait,
what? What did he just pull up for the chat? >> Illinois
judge overseeing this case is expected to hear. >> He just
pulled up a chat here. Uh, why the did you shock your dog, you
dumb deleted by NFAS >> oral arguments on Thursday.
>> Is there like a LSF video or something? Is that why
there's like hella people coming in here and and screeching?
Is that what's going on? Oh, classic.
It started on D, then H3, then LSF is a classic pipeline.
I'm going to
>> Yes, I am incredibly abusive
to the not only best trained, but also the best behaving and
most spoiled dog on the planet is from when Kai yelled. Yeah,
she yelled because she clipped herself on something when she
was getting off the bed. Did she? Did she Hassan?
14220 is PO POG was saying. Okay. 14220.
I kind of want to keep listening to what Hassan said. We didn't
really go through this much. >> Growing push to send troops
into US cities. The state of Illinois.
>> And the city of Chicago filed a lawsuit to stop the
president from deploying hundreds of national. And in Oregon,
a federal judge blocked a similar deployment to Portland. The
president is now threatening to invoke the insurrection act to
go around the courts. Adam Yamaguchi is in Portland. Adam, good
morning. So, what are you seeing there?
>> Good morning, Wild. >> Okay. Are you on a different
VOD? I think you're looking at a VOD with like extra stuff on
it. Are you looking Oh, 124 1240. N 14240. I see. I see. I see.
>> Right here where she gets up. I got it. We got it. We're
locked in >> the city of
>> Jesus Christ. Still on this. Um, yeah, I guess. So,
I don't I don't know why people feel the need to come in and
say that.
That's, by the way, that's uh I just want to just show logs for
this guy really quickly. The guy who came in and said this. Hold
on. I just want to I just want to show
I'm going to I'm going to throw this up. Now, there's nothing
wrong with this with just lurking. This is the only message this
guy's ever thrown in this chat before. Apparently, at least the
past I don't know if it's like a year retention or something.
It's the only message he's ever thrown in the chat. Jesus Christ.
Still on this? I think that's just funny. Really, man? You're
still on this? Listen, I think this is fun. I like going through
and excluding these things, okay?
I I think I think a lot of people might be getting scared by
the title, okay? I think that's what's happening. I think a lot
of people are seeing me stay.
We're going to end Color Gate today. It's over. One way or another,
this ends today. And I think a lot of people are seeing a lot
of zeros disappear from their next check from whatever platform
they make content on. Okay? They're they're er they're being
erased. They're being deleted in real time and they're getting
a little concerned that I'm just going to end this once and for
all today that it will be over. There will be no more confusion.
There will be no more anything. We're done. Okay. After today,
by the way, still a decent chance we're done. And Hassan's guilty
and he, you know, gets the electric chair. Okay.
But one way or another,
we're ending it. It's got to be done. It's got to be over today.
>> 133 square miles. It's all been confined to this one
city block.
>> What do we got here? What do we got here? We don't even
see the air tag coming through at all. >> Protesters on
both sides of this issue. >> That's a rough one. I don't
think we see anything there. >> Relatively peaceful during
the day. Last night to an area about 133.
>> We see air tag. We don't see anything else.
See air tag. We don't see our box. We don't see a light.
We don't see our box.
miles.
It's all been confined to this one city block.
>> He doesn't say kaya, he says down. >> Last night,
we spoke to protesters on both sides of this issue, and they
agreed that the demonstrations remain relatively calm despite
more people showing up later into the evening. During the day,
there's been only a dozen or so protesters here blocking the
driveway of this ICE facility. And at night, that number grows
to around a hundred. Last night, we asked protesters
why they're here and if they're concerned their presence could
fuel Trump's argument that the National Guard is needed.
>> If the National Guard's here and you push all this stuff
out, they actually
>> uh it's towards the back of her neck. No, the heavenlies
are that's not it. And I can show you. Hold on. I should have
actually labeled which one this was, but I took one of these
and made sure that we had it for later because one of these I
think it's this one basically like conclusively shows that at
the top >> of celebrity news and the things primarily transphobic
and anti-semitic narrative. She also denies the Holocaust and
says the real ethnic cleansing was of German. She's a grifter.
Yeah, it's >> Not this one. I'll find the the actual one.
One of my time stamps literally just shows the top of her head
and how that piece at the top of her head is not >> atrocities
for seven >> is not Oh, maybe this one. It's like not actually
the it can't be the tag up there, right? Or it can't be the um
it can't be the box up there cuz you can see through this that
we've got like fur. This black piece here is actually a part
of her fur. That's like a black streak in her a dark streak in
her fur right here. It is not in fact the
the e-collar
point after the culmination of of
>> you see that it looks right here right here it looks
like it could be the e-collar yes
but it is in fact not
>> it is in fact just a shock of fur that happens to be
like black or shaded in some way I think it is very dark fur
because it seems from other angles like it could be something
attached to the color but you can see here that there's a lightning
of hair there that shows it's not attached to the color. It is
in fact just hair. That's all it is. Man, I don't know why you
think that's incredible. So, I think a lot of people just parse
the full argument of him sucking off Islamic cults is that like
I think there's a genocide going on. And over time, as Israel
got far more like insane with their approach to Gaza, he looked
more correct. I can see why people didn't hate him for that approach.
This one there's just no reason to like be abusive to your dog
and that's how he's being painted. So, of course, this one sticks
more, right? There's no way a dog could do anything to deserve
this in most people's minds. That's true. The real Dr. Cube,
unfortunately, I can't deal with I can't read Hassan's mind.
I'm just trying to use the facts we have in front of us. Okay,
the facts we have in front of us, the visible evidence. These
are the these are my tools, okay? The the psychology, that's
like a different thing. That's like a memeing thing. Okay, when
somebody's life doesn't hang in the balance. All right, I don't
need to I don't need to read his mind. 157 is our next time stamp
going on here.
tactical skepticism.
Uh, I'm literally just going, you watch me go through all of
this. You can't say tactical skepticism when I go through every
clip. We've we've watched every clip of her getting up here over
and over and over again. You can't accuse me of tactical
I'm just going through and doing the work. Okay, hold on. We're
going day two's another time stamp here and then we'll go to
the next time stamp. Again, you're asking me to hypothesize about
things that I'm not currently doing. I don't know why she did
that. Moist and crusty. I don't have to do that. I don't have
to engage in any theory at all for that. I just have to go through
and see if she's actually wearing the e-collar. Right. That's
all I got to do. Uh the real Dr. Cube, I can already tell. Listen,
we've we've had a lot of people go through this same um
oh, like the same simple machine, the same like finite state
machine that you're going through. You're now on the like, wait,
but Hassan could have just said this after he went through the
VOD himself and saw that you couldn't see it. Yeah, that's possible.
Yeah, I don't worry. We we've already gone through your whole
finite state machine. I see where you're going. I I would understand
that you probably couldn't just say like definitively,
but I I've seen a lot of looks on this collar where it looks
like definitive that that e-collar is not there. He absolutely
has a shot color and we've Yeah, Heavenlies are you've just missed
most of the stream. That's okay. Maybe I'll do a write up after
the stream and just show all of this for people so that they
can understand better. Um, yes, he does have a shot color. Yes,
he has multiple colors. They all have Air Tags on them. For the
collar that is an e-collar, uh, he has the air tag between the
e-collar portion and the buckle. We've basically identified where
that is and been unable to see the e-collar, the light from it,
or the full box from it anywhere. We've not been able to see
it in any of the VODs from that day. Have you considered that
Hassan is bad though? I am.
I am. I have every every prejudice against Hassan. Okay? I am
the person who is principled. All right? I'm the ACLU lawyer
who was raised as a part of the KKK and through great effort
overcame my programming, my my programmed hatred for this one
individual, this type of individual, and I am now willing to
defend them based on my principled commitment to upholding the
law and equality for all. Okay, that's who I am right now. I'm
obviously just joking. I'm just having fun going through it.
>> Sorry, I looked at I I went way past the previous uh
Sorry, Pool gave me another time stamp and I've been yapping
instead of actually going to the time stamp. Give me a second.
15749. That's where we are.
Oh, we got a lot of movement around here. Hold on. This is a
big movement time right here. This is the biggest movement time
we've seen in a little while. Let me get this time stamp.
>> Let's take a look.
This is not a genuine change of >> what I'm arguing right
now, Dinglingus, is that given him leaning over, given the fact
that he showed an e-collar, given the fact that I'd never heard
him claim she wasn't wearing the e-collar on this day, I was
like, "Oh, I think like the most likely if I had to bet on one
of these things, it's probably a shock." But but you have to
understand that opinion is like 40 to 50% uncertainty and like
probably 20 30% shock, right? Like, and then there's a whole
bunch of other things that go off into nowhere. So, I'm saying
probably if I had to bet on only bet on only one possibility,
it would be that he shocked her. But I still felt like there
was a lot of uncertainty there. Now, I'm just going through after
he's now claimed that she wasn't even wearing that collar that
day. I'm just going through the VOD to see if it's there
cuz I like I just like to be accurate, you know?
That's enjoyable for me
at all.
>> Okay. So, we would maybe expect to see over the bottom
here. Do we see
Let me go back. Let me go back. Let me go back.
Uh, no, you see the the faint impression through the fur, but
you don't see on the bottom anything to do with the collar. We're
expecting to be on the bottom on the other side.
>> Let's take another look. >> Ka is going down for
the count here. She kind of leans out. We don't see very much.
We see the top of the color there. >> I think we have a
lot of other definitive looks that show that that E- color is
not on top. >> She voted for the [__] bill,
dude. >> we see I think essentially nothing here that shows
me
>> I think as she goes down maybe we see
>> let's see as she goes down we get this side view here
we get a little view of the air tag we get nothing we got nothing
we got top of the collar up >> and this may be just shakes
her head
>> yeah she voted for the bill dude she voted for the bill
to cut $800 billion >> by the way
I will say oh she's about to scratch She's about to scratch.
Okay, she's about to scratch and scratch.
Let's see. Cuz at any point in time here, we would expect for
the shot collar to do its green pulse, right? The e-collar should
do the green pulse at some point. Nicholas banned me when I told
him he had a cake that Hassan was lying in this clip about her
not wearing the collar. Uh he turned into such a lowcal. Listen,
we don't know. We still don't technically know at any point here.
It could be that uh it could be the case that she scratches and
the color flicks out into view and you see the green light, right?
You see the green light somewhere.
You could you could still see that. That could still happen.
That's literally why we have to be thorough, right? We don't
want to just go, "Oh, well, I think I see that it's not there,
and I'm going to go say it's not there." We have to be It's all
about being thorough. Okay, hold on.
Let me go through here. We're looking. We're looking. She's going
to scratch. We see our tag now. >> Wait, didn't she also
work at TYT?
>> Marie Taylor Green. No,
>> man. I would expect you to see it here, right? I would
I would totally expect it to be poking through here. >> Wait,
didn't she also work at TYT
Mar?
>> I think we see another definitive look showing it's
not on top, right?
Like there is just no way to say that this this e-collar is on
top. It has to be somewhere here.
>> Has to be. So, so it has to be like here hidden under
the fur.
Why is the buckle so far away from the air tag though? Wait,
why do you think the buckle's far away from the air tag? >> Killer
green. No, >> hold on. The buckle the buckle's right here.
This is the top of the buckle. This is the bottom of the buckle.
We've already seen like where this buckle >> even if there
is any loophole in the law >> like you see the bottom of
the buckle now, right? The the buckle is tight to the air tag.
It's not far away. So, we got buckle, we got air tag. We would
expect right here e-collar >> law that would prevent this
money from going to federal workers after the
easily close that loophole in whatever
>> Now you would expect somewhere here that we should see
>> like do you see how the top do you see how the top of
the air tag pushes the hair up? Even when she's scratching it
still pushes the hair up and we don't get any of that effect
here where we would expect it
after the shutdown.
Congress could
>> so here maybe hold on let's see
hold on is that no I don't think so >> easily close that
>> that's
I don't see it there
but am I even if there
>> do you see like looking right here do we see how this
like patch it's like pushing up
the patch is like pushing up sorry not the patch patch. The air
tag is like pushing this this patch of hair up and I would just
expect some similar effect to be seen here at any point
from the e-collar. >> There is any loophole in the law
that would prevent this.
>> So I also I'm hoping that if we are going to see something
that we would see
>> after the shut. See, I also feel like you see the the
we're not we don't see like the the protruding out here, >> but
it is possible that we just have, you know, neck fat, neck fur
getting in the way >> that loophole and
>> like we can we see at minimum color here. Again, it's
the the e-collar is bigger. I think what we should be seeing
here is the light. No, >> whatever bill they pass, >> this
is a scary time for so many families. All right, that Ryan, thank
you. We have an e-coller here. >> Hey, thanks for watching
and don't forget you can catch the Today Show every morning on
NBC or take
on the go. >> Uh, that's what I think. Fourth Jan. Yes,
the Shocker thing is to the left of the tag. Oh, well then it's
over, right? If it's to the left of the tag, we've got the buckle
right here. We can see this tight and no box here at all. So,
if you think it's over here on this side, which you're wrong
about that, just so you know.
But
if if you thought it was on this side, it's over. We're definitively
ruled out that side of the buckle and the air tag being there.
Okay. Or sorry, the uh the e-collar being there. The room is
probably too bright for the light plus how far away? Uh well,
the light came through plenty fine in this clip, right? >> Light
comes through in this. Oh, whoops. There it was. >> Right.
The light's like very obvious here. Uh hold on. I need to zoom
out a little bit.
It's like very very obvious. Now, the orientation here is flipped.
So, we expect the light to be on the top side, right? We expect
the light to be on the top side based on what we have confirmed
the caller's orientation to be.
We'd expect the light to be on this side. So this is the angle
where I would expect us to see the light. If we don't see the
light here, well,
that gets concerning. Okay. So that's the next day.
That's the next day. Um, if if you believe that that's the color
she's wearing here,
there's definitive evidence, right, that to the left of that
Air Tag, there is nothing.
Like, we could just go through this and I we've gone through
the time stamps on this left side, further up towards the top
of her head, there is no e-collar. The only thing that we have
any possible hope for if you want Hassan to be proven to have
had the e-collar and the dog here is you need the the the e-collar
to be here under uh there is hair covering it. You're hoping
you'd see a peek through of the light >> every morning
on >> So we go back. There is there are some frames here
that like >> Hey, thanks for watching and don't forget
you can catch the Today Show. >> Maybe try to argue. It
looks like the color it doesn't look like it holds anything up.
Oh, maybe with the shake. Do we get anything on the headshake
here? Do we get anything through on the headshake at all?
>> Oh, maybe. Is that your best look? That might be your
new best look right there at what could maybe be the box,
but it's like it's literally getting this like laggy headshake
going on. Maybe argue something here.
But again, I don't know how you So this this looks like you could
maybe argue that if that's like the best you're hoping for >> or
has she her head here? Oh, hold on. >> Don't forget. >> Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. You can catch the Today Show. just saw
on NBC. >> Now, hold on. As we go Oh, no. It's uh it's
something else there. Okay. Yeah. I don't know, man. I was thinking
maybe you could see like the the
I was thinking maybe you could see the
>> That's it. You think this is it?
Man, I see how you you would you would hope that's it. If you
want Hassan to get caught here, I would say that's
But I like I I'm now looking for anything else that looks like
it cuz I can see this is like hope, right? This is like hope
on the on the anti-hassan side. And I I don't think I can extinguish
that hope. >> I would expect, you know, some still shot
where we don't have the things
I I see the air. Yeah. The issue is here is you don't know you
don't know how stuff's like mixing together here, right?
Like you don't see the full air tag in some instances. I'd say
that's your best hope. Do we know that this is not hair, not
anything?
I don't know, man.
Like that's that's a lighter color right there.
I think that's your best hope. So, I'm going to say inconclusive
for now and we keep looking. But maybe there's some hope left
on this other side. Okay. I thought there was no hope.
I was I was I thought there was no hope,
but there may be hope. See if the black blob moves back exactly
in line with the air tag. I'm saying I can't tell with this like
it's not in a place with it moving fast for us to be able to
know for sure, right? Like I don't know if this overrides all
of the other clips we've seen yet. JTO is just milking now. There
is no e-collar there. I mean I don't believe there's an e-collar
there. I'm kind of milking but like you know we're we're just
investigating, man.
We're just looking. She's on.
Uh because TYT uh interviews her. That's it. She's not actually.
>> Oh, I wasn't watching there if we got any other views.
>> Um I was thinking, by the way, I was thinking about
just doing this off
>> I was I was think about just doing this off stream and
I was like, "Oh, I should just do this on stream." Obviously,
you cannot see the light straight on. Had to be a specific angle.
Uh yeah, I agree with you. I I do think that if you could see
the edge here at all that you could see it like right where she's
moving around at the green light was on. I'm saying I'm not saying
we have to see that green light to prove that it's there. I'm
saying that green light would give us definitive proof that it's
there. If we saw the green light, you think 36 in the first VOD
is where you could see it better if it's there. Hold on. Back
first VOD >> that cuz that >> again this is first
VOD. Oh, the are responsible for the death of like 60 million
Christians narrative is like a white conversation that you're
a >> like that's not even your gripe. You know what I mean?
That's not a conversation that you're a part of at all. It's
also a ridiculous statement to begin with. >> The light
is not always on. It flashes on and off >> because like
you know the Bullshiks are >> 365. Okay. So this we just
got a different first VOD from each other then somehow
I need to go back to whatever this one is cuz this one's not
working for some reason. Let's go. Videos 107 365 107 part one
in pro Palestinian advocacy
>> land the ancient land of Israel >> because we
are certainly not the least and maybe the most indigenous people
to the to the region until you >> dude you're Polish. >> This
VOD Why would this be Hold on. Why would this be the case?
Oh, you're working off of a bad V, aren't you?
>> Maybe not. I think I think some of the VODs work with
this 365
>> news and true crime to fit primarily transphobic and
anti-semitic narrative. She also denies the Holocaust and says
the real ethnic cleansing was of German.
>> So, you think, wait, you think you get a better view
of like the box here? I don't know about that. You think like
you think this piece like kind of right here is proving the box
is there?
I don't know. I don't know, man. I don't I don't think so. I
don't think that's a better view. Oh, unless Hold on. Maybe there's
a better version here. Maybe we keep going. I still see roughly
this same like kind of bottom aligned collar piece going through
here. Right. I don't see the box more light. Like by the way,
that is that is shadow right there as it's dropping down.
Yeah. Like once you get the shadow dropping down, right? So this
like this appears. So she's got like this under the fur and it
sort of like appears
with a shadow going through. Right. No, I don't I don't think
that's a better view. I don't think there's something there in
this one. Anyway, I I respect your opinion on this. I just uh
I don't think there's a better view on that one. Okay.
Now, where are we going next? Oh, should I switch over to kick?
I'll switch over to kick only for a little bit, guys. We're going
over kick only. Twitchers. Twitchers, head over to kick. We'll
see you there shortly. Okay, we'll see you there shortly. All
right. All right. Let us continue on. Uh this was what 158 or
so around here. Let me grab this time stamp. Throw in the document.
Okay, we got that time stamp in the document. Exostasis, that's
not even what we're
hole in the law that would prevent. >> Thank you. >> Hey,
thanks for watching and don't forget you can catch the Today
Show every morning on >> Thank you. >> Hey, thanks.
After the shutdown, Congress could easily close that loophole
in whatever bill they pass. >> this is a scary time for
so many families. All right, Ryan, thank you. >> Hey, thank
What is that? Hold on. Was
I seeing something there? Am I hallucinating? Am I hallucinating?
Maybe >> whatever bill they pass. >> This is a scary
time for so many families. All right, that Ryan, thank >> Yeah,
I was hallucinating.
>> I mean, I guess this is your your best hope if you're
on this side
is like here it appears like there could maybe you could maybe
argue there's something there. >> Hey, thanks for watching
and don't forget you can catch. But then you have to explain
why when she turns her head,
why like
when she turns her head, you've got such a clear view of this
and not the not what could be the box there. Why there's no push
back of the fur in the way that the rest of this stuff pushes
back the >> watching. And don't forget, you can catch the
Today Show every morning on NBC or take on when you're on the
go. >> Uh because TYT uh interviews her. That's it. She's
not actually.
>> We're going to begin though with a growing impact of
>> covered with deck meat. That's what people say. But
why is there no other screenshot of it being covered with neck
meat in the same way? Uh what am I doing here? Hey, Twitch is
off. We're back over on kick only. Okay. All right.
>> let's keep looking. >> Also, ATC has been >> I'm
looking for the next time she moves kind of tangibly.
She leans her head down here. workers who are not air traffic
controllers in the town. >> Her head down. She scratches
her nose.
>> Meaning there was
air traffic control staffing went to >> scratching more
here. Ooh, maybe we get something here. Hold on.
meaning there was no one in the control
>> We got nothing. Pilots
were redirected to
at other FAA facilities.
>> I thought we could have had something.
>> We got nothing. >> We got nothing.
>> And flyers felt the impact. >> They rerouted us
to LAX
and they gave us a voucher. >> Staffing issues, including
sick calls, hit several major airports and ATC centers on day
six.
government shutdown. >> Yeah. And it's also for the shutdown.
So >> I'm gonna start looking. >> This is something
that we literally talked about. >> This is something that
we talked about >> Lay down fully. Okay. She goes to lay
her head down fully. >> We can see some stuff here. And
a Blackhawk army
of real. But of
It's the DEI.
He's dead, man. And how is it his fault?
Look up Ronald Reagan ATC to find out
Pyramid is on. >> Okay, we're looking for Are we getting
any movement here? We're not getting any
>> President Ronald Reagan speech about the air traffic
controller strike. He stayed very clear. She's going to be gone
after this. So, this is the last view we're going to get of this.
Yeah. I just Kane, I feel like probably you should just not want
people who are like psychotic, right? You you should probably
just not want actual psychopaths who don't feel like human empathy
for anything. being the people who lead you politically. You
probably just want you probably just want to avoid people without
any conscience.
Um, so if Assan were somebody who abused his dog like all the
time, I feel like that's somebody you wouldn't want involved
in politics probably, unless you're just looking for the most
entertaining psychopath. >> Do not report to work in 48
hours. They'll be far from their jobs. The
Andrew Lewis Jr. >> Okay. Well, I thought
increase in salaries and benefits. >> All right. All right.
This might be our last
might be our last look at Kaa for this day. [__]
>> Agreement was reached and signed by both
>> granting a $40 million
increase in salaries and benefits.
This is twice.
>> Why did this not pause? >> I got nothing there.
I don't think there's anything. Is there
>> Why is this
goes by with this guy.
>> We got nothing. Oh, hold on.
>> What other government?
>> Oh, we got we got nothing. >> Expect it was granted
and >> nothing. Ka does not come back on this
>> Ka gone for the rest of this day.
What am I supposed >> Oh, Kaya knock on for the rest of
this day because like >> Now, here's the real question.
You know what I'm going to look for here, right?
You know what I'm going to look for? Does the color's orientation
change? If she comes back, is the color suddenly facing like
a different direction or something? I don't even know what we
think at that point. What would we even think?
It's hard to say.
>> Gave her the place command while she was getting off.
And oh well here she coming back somewhere in here >> autobiographical
and other
much outside of like a decent Sabrina Carpenter feature but yeah
unfortunately a truly forgettable ending to an album that um
starts a lot stronger than it finishes. But yeah that's uh the
life of a show girl I guess. Sadly I'm very torn
>> Did I lose connection again? Am I still
>> Can you guys see me? This keeps happening today. >> I
really do like this album. Was >> annoying. Please.
>> Taylor Swift had to >> Oh, hold on. >> It's
very annoying. >> I do want to see her go by there.
>> You got any view? We got >> Taylor Swift had to
offer this time around one breath. I really do
>> like that this album was poppier, catchier, punchier,
more direct to the and all that.
do tend to agree that there are songs that she wrote when she
was a teenager or in her early 20s that comparatively to many
songs
that she wrote when she was a teenager or in her early 20s
>> I saw do you see how skitso I am at this point you guys
see what I've become
hold on is this little light right here I saw go on and I'm like
oh my god is that it is that it
seems to just be a can inside. I think it's just a can. I think
it's just a >> That comparatively to >> It's just
a can, man. It's just a can. We're fine. We're making >> many
songs on this album are more mature and more poetic. But I mean,
you don't even need to go back that far. Just look at some of
the autobiographical and otherwise writing. Uh that was >> Nick
told us he's over folklore and evermore. like just years ago,
Taylor was writing immensely more mature and and and smarter
tracks that had just a lot uh >> I forgot this was a Taylor
Swift album release here. Okay,
get her moving around anymore here. I don't know if we get any
other movement here. Like I don't know if we're going to get
another look at this. I'd like another look at it. >> Normal
people know that you obviously don't abuse your dog, dude. I
know, but
abnormal people are. There's literally one person pushing this
because he's coping about being a terrible dog owner who lets
his animal [__] everywhere. Yeah. Does that make
sense?
>> I don't mean
cross that way.
>> Insults you'll ever read and a lot of >> dogg
still laying down. Dog is very
>> Most loyal of swift. >> Oh, come on. She can't
be asleep the rest of the stream, can she? No.
>> It's joy. And the lyrics might not be >> with
people express >> she he could possibly have that she would
need to sell.
>> All right. Right here is where she gets >> here's
another kind of album that you release under an authoritarian
regime. That's a comment someone left in my initial album reaction
video. >> And let me >> Okay, this is our last look.
What was that? What was that? >> Let me tell you all the
reasons why that's true. In our current political she Oh, she's
going. She's going. We get anything in between the No, we don't.
H I think I see the I think I see the That might be the white
of the Air Tag there. Maybe. Maybe. And now the UI of YouTube
is getting in the way. God damn it.
>> I I don't think we're getting much else >> Climate
of a government shutdown.
>> No, I don't think so. I don't think we're getting anything
else here.
So, oh man, that's just rough, dude. That's just rough. I don't
think uh look at this transcript. Okay, let's see.
or shock. Shocking. Shocking. Shocked her with a button. Yeah,
my evil villain >> is going to be in the next content.
Nuke, I'm confused. How did she get shocked or is that fake there?
I don't There is no way for her to be shocked. That is fake.
>> Okay. Oh man, I'm starting to see how this happened
to him. The parasocial are >> I'm actually starting to
see how like he might not have had that collar on that day and
then he was being accused of hiding that collar because he had
another collar that is like that kind of collar that he didn't
have it on with. Right. Look at the next day after the collar
reveal. At first the e-collar is obvious but near the end the
air tag is the only thing that shows. Okay, this would be helpful.
This would be very helpful. Accelerate. Let's take a look. Let's
take a look.
You know on Monday afternoon, Donald Trump aid went on CN News
Central to discuss the president's deployment of
>> you know on Monday afternoon went on >> I see
that it's the the air tank is the thing we see >> that's
what we see in there. Okay, that's giving me an idea that it
could be that the air tag is pulling the impression back a lot
more than anything
This is very interesting to me. Okay, it's very interesting.
You see legal dick suckers new vid where he is getting gangstaled.
Yeah, we did the I you guys keep going to like what is he doing
when he reaches over? We're just trying to establish what this
looks like. Okay.
Oh, sorry. Sorry. Junarch, what you need to understand here is
we do actually have the caller on this stream. Okay. This stream,
she does have the caller on. Uh, Accelerate, do you still have
that first time stamp for when you can see the caller on her?
Believe it's on the other side in this one. Legal dick sucker
is the Ethan Ralph name for legal mindset, guys.
It's the Ethan Ralph name.
been rehearsing this argument to roll out at a later date and
I think that that might not be far off maybe
>> uh I'm waiting Accelerate I could hold on let me look
through your logs I could probably find through your logs uh
where this other time stamp was
got this one here and then
looking through your logs
>> actively trying to go as a a >> so right Here
we could see.
Wait, we do see the collar on on this day, don't we? >> If
you are
here, we can see what she >> Engaging in anti-fascist demonstrations.
>> This is where she's got one of them. Now, I will say
Oh, it's down further. And it does. It's sitting here. I see.
I see. Oh, it sits a little further away than I expected. And
it poofs out further away than I expected.
Okay, that's now I will say that seems to be showing a little
bit more there. This literally proves everything. That's going
to be a meme screenshot. Obviously, I know Emer wouldn't just
send me something that would be helpful. There's no way. You're
just You're not going to send me anything. It's probably Charlie
Day. If it's Charlie Day, I might have to ban you for being unoriginal.
Oh, it's not. Okay.
It's a little amus guy. Wow. Wow. Wow.
Okay. So, it's it is further down than you'd expect with how
it sits here and
>> Oh god, how did I start this? I'm going to turn it down
and play it. >> You are saying that anti-fascism is a
>> Now, I will say
I would expect us to have one angle Accelerati where it shows
better, right? You would expect that, right? Hold on. We got
30. Kais not there not there not there
>> or other temporary language hard claiming something
like
go I don't know take a look at her right here where she gets
up oh she flicks up
>> Now, let me ask you something. Okay,
>> let me ask you guys something.
>> We see it. We kind of see it there.
>> not super. Well, >> was she shocked for this one
>> to get up that aggressively? Was she shocked here? >> I
just don't I don't understand
>> and like what the what the distinction is there, you
know?
We watched the CNN video. We all
>> said Trump deployed the National Guard. I don't know
where
glitched you know Donald Trump aid went on SN
>> given how she leans true US cities SN asked Miller when
the Trump administration will see in Oregon.
What I would like to see is now one where you could see sort
of like the whole collar and it doesn't look like the box is
there because we have issues or we have areas where we can see
the under the collar and you can't really see the box. >> So
I'm wondering if we could get another angle like that from this
day.
Well, the administr
feels like it's going to be unlikely.
>> I guess like for me
>> at 1930
in
was editing
whether the
>> we saw it together. You were in the chat. Had you rewind
video on Twitter? No, I watched.
>> See, there's another one where you could kind of see
it peeking through because of how well it shows up.
>> You don't see the other you were pissing in the chat.
Had you rewind? No. No. I
>> Oh, you see the box? The box is so much further down
than you'd expect here. Me.
You guys see that? how when she moves like the box is way further
away than I'd expect >> after the fact on a separate
>> No, I >> she moves over and like the box is probably
starting to be here.
>> Oh, boy. This is a tough one, man. It's a tough one,
man.
>> I'm starting to I'm starting to get concerned, guys.
I'll be real with you. >> I'm starting to get concerned
that we might not resolve this fully today. We might not be able
to say we killed this controversy today in either direction
>> and that's very disappointing to me. >> I might
also need some caffeine.
>> They're a little bit better. But I would say that we're
we're an example of how you don't need to be part of a super
large company to be able to do just basic journalism. All you
got to do is sit and record.
>> Hold on. Scanning. We're we're just scanning through
for more kaya movement on this day to see if we could
what we could see with the caller going on here.
Every single person here maybe maybe not personally, but I've
>> Oh my god, what's up? Oh, that sucks.
>> Seen them get, you know, hunted down and attacked. And
so, um, incredible group that is responsible for a good percentage,
if not a bad, >> she's not even of the violent riots in
2021 and 2020 when Democrat mayors >> Oh, hold on. >> that
is responsible for a good percentage, if not a majority of the
violent riots in 2021 and 2020 when Democrat
mayors had a kind of a hands-off approach with these left-wing
militants. goes out. Okay. All right,
man. No, we we found basically one thing that looks like it could
be it Kilo at one point later on in the stream,
but we did sort of also find that there are points where you
can see the box in this stream when she's wearing it, like the
the e-collar box, but it does get sort of covered and it doesn't
push the fur away quite as effectively as the Air Tag like you'd
expect with Eric, but we're not going to. Right. So, how >> and
Antifa uses
>> there's a difference, >> man. I have to I have
to get some caffeine, though. Holy. I just kind of have been
doing this the whole time without without watching how fast the
time faded away, guys. That's three and a half hours off the
stream. Holy [__]
Holy [__] What do we have left for the day? Oh my
god. We've got the entirety. Oh, we've still got a bunch of other
that we want to look at. Um, somebody linked the Dan stream.
Let's take a look at that.
Let's uh let's review the
anything else stream where Dan shows how easily the prongs can
be removed.
Um
and then I'm going to go into the JF stuff cuz the JF stuff should
be funny. 17-ish minutes I'm being told. 17-ish minutes
when he starts >> like what? 5%.
>> No, I'm starting at 10. >> so Dan Dan puts the
collar on and Dan is going to start chalking. Listen, I'm down
to watch Dan zap himself like he's Keels. Okay. Keles did this
for subs. Now Dan's doing it for subs. You love to see it. All
right. Can somebody find me that clip of Keeles shocking herself?
Hold on. Ke's shock collar
stream. Oh, is this going to be the Kefl thing? No, it's not.
Oh Jesus. I I just put Keles's shocker stream and I'm not getting
any I'm literally If you put shot stream into Google, you are
not getting anything about Keles. It's just all wallto-wall Hassan
right now.
Right. It's just wall to- wall hassan all over the place. And
I I can't find the the shock thing. Holy holy moly. Okay. All
right. >> Okay. 10%.
>> And that's the that's the T button, >> Or is that
vibrate?
>> Vibrate. T was vibrate. >> Oh. Oh, [__]
me. Okay, I'm going to do the please be at 10%.
Oh, >> no shot, >> dude. It's a It's a [__]
It goes across, bro. It goes across.
>> dude. It's a shock. I You shocked myself a lot when
I'm doing electrical work. This is me getting shocked. >> Oh,
okay. That's only at 10%. All right,
I'll go up. I'll go up a little bit >> Okay, go up to 20.
>> Okay, it's really tight. I'm scared. >> Well,
Ka's she couldn't even fit a finger under there. Okay,
>> I I can fit one finger. I'm blinking. I'm blinking here.
Okay. After this, look, we're we're doing the tear down of it
for the impossible adamantium.
Uh, show the remote so we see the level. Sorry, it's >> you're
going to move your fat head.
>> Oh, yeah. We see it. 20%. >> 20%. Here we go.
>> Let's Let's see. 20%. >> He's got it up at 20%.
Here we go. >> Oh, you get the red light. Okay. You get
the red light going on when it gets used. Interesting.
Hold on. Comparison. Comparison. What do you guys think? Oh,
she's just tasing herself.
I see. Tasing herself for subs.
Wow.
>> That's not funny. Off, bro. >> Dude, your face
is hilarious. That's
>> No, it's it's not enjoyable, bro. What the Okay. Okay.
All right. Hold on. It actually It feels like you're getting
shocked. I mean, I guess that kind of makes sense. Why is his
son saying this is enjoyable? He's like, "Oh, yeah. I use this
for All right, hold on. We'll go up to
30. I mean, it's not as bad as when I shocked myself off of the
110. I've done that before. Okay, hold on.
>> there we are. 30%.
>> I'm like I'm like making sure I don't accidentally press
the button cuz this one right here >> that's that we're
going to play that later. We're going to have to hit that one.
Okay,
this is the last. We got to take a break after this cuz it's
a little bit much. Dude, it sucks to do it to yourself. What
about if I do it and then I just like my my muscles?
>> Keep doing it. >> All right.
Okay.
You have to say Dan place. >> Wait, is it
>> Dan? Maybe
>> Oh, was that not that bad or
>> This sucks. All right, that's that's 30%. That's 30%.
>> You got >> I know of what Ka >> got. Sean's
doing this, dude. I'm I would be tweaking for the vibrate thing.
Oh my god. The vibrate thing even gives you PTSD right now. It
does. You get PTSD with a vibrate thing. >> Let's see your
neck. Let's >> Damn. I truly I believe a dog would get
PTSD in that same way. Dogs Dogs don't even know. Dogs can't
even intellect. >> See if there's barks or anything yet.
>> Barks. Marks. >> Hold on. We got this one and
then >> hold on. >> He breaks it down in about 45
minutes. It's It's I'm being told. Okay. So, it's just going
to be him shocking himself. >> Major major payout here.
>> Not good. >> Yeah, exactly. Um,
>> hold on. Let him >> take a look. >> He's
showing him. He's showing it again.
>> Wait, you got it up to 65. >> All right.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait.
>> Wait. I have to make sure I got to make sure it's a
little bit tighter.
>> He's such a baby. >> But Oh, don't be a It's a
The rivet. Absolutely riveting content, though. >> Who
knew that when Darius As Darius's star falls,
Dan Star arises in the self harm streamer category. Okay,
>> let's go. >> It's not good on your head, bro.
It's going down in my arm.
It's going down in my arm and my
>> I feel it here. You know what it feels like if you bang
your
>> You can see that like
>> Sharp. Oh, there's got to be one in
>> Got it. Got a Sharpie. Boom. You know what this is?
It's a Sharpie. Okay, dude. My hands Look, my hands are still
shaking. I'm
Hold on.
>> Dude, you're shaky. Yeah. >> This is This is All
right. First off, Taylor Lauren, >> you compare this more
to Keles. Oh, I already did. It's funny theory. His number was
written in a Sharpie on this right here somehow. Apparently,
well, first off, let's uh I want to remove Where's the tool?
So, remember this thing has two >> Oh, I think I said that
Taylor Loren was a for this, right? Oh, you can't you can't remove
these >> levels of prongs. It's not that much >> Move
the cam down a little bit. We can't see. Okay, you're good. The
one thing I'm interested in, I heard Dan cut the prongs off with
the pliers. Okay. And then after that was still able to shock
himself really badly. >> So there's two levels of prongs.
>> So I'm kind of interested to see if that's how that
works. >> The size difference on them. >> It's like
what? It's like >> nothing really cuz it'll be torqued
on. Actually, I can I can take this one off. Where's that cool?
>> Hold on. >> Did you check out the Sasha Gray clip?
Yeah. I mean, I'm sorry. Sorry. I just don't put any stock in
the like biggest morons on the internet to get anything right.
You know what I'm saying? Like those people are just stupid.
I Sasha, I'm sorry. If I wanted to know, you know, if I wanted
a really informed opinion on how appto mouth tastes, I would
totally consult Sasha Gray. Okay, that's what I would be. She's
like the expert on that. All right. But in terms of like identifying
from clips, like from evidence what's going on in anything at
any given time, no, that's not my I'm not seeking her opinion
on
Oh, there it is. Okay, let's take this one off. >> That's
No, it's not.
>> So, you can see the best way I can do this. Hold on.
>> I got an idea. I can go down lower.
>> Tell him to test the Sharpie first so people don't >> Wait,
he's trying it with the lead screwed on. >> Don't say,
"Oh, that Sharpie has no >> That's not what I thought."
>> What? No, that vertically. >> Hold on. >> We
got here for girth
that you can put there. Yeah. Yes. >> Thank you. >> Hold
on. >> I just want to make sure that it's >> Four.
I would say that's 5 mm right around either side. >> Do
you have a light that you can put
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Did you see this? Is it going to be
footage of K? >> The internet is absolutely f
>> No, I didn't see this.
Uh, I didn't see this at all.
Again, we're mostly just analyzing whether or not she's wearing
the collar at all in the first stream. Zage, that's what we've
been doing the whole time. The comments in Sasha Grey's LSF thread
are mildly amusing. I bet they are.
>> Thank you. >> Hold on. >> I just want to
make sure that it's
>> How is that? >> Good.
Perfect. Now, >> hold on. Trying to
It should be like
>> You see the dislike? So, it's defense.
>> there's no way. There's no way that's true, right? that
the this dislike to dislike ratio means it's defending Hassan
[__] This guy makes it seem like the kind of color
that only vibrates. Oh well, >> I can do the different
colors. Do you like the Yeah, that's the I fix it >> I
fix it color. >> This is the I fix it color. Okay. >> What
are we doing, man? We take the prongs off. >> You can see
the ejection moldable thing is she's going to say you can't take
a welder's torch to it. Yes. >> My guess is what she meant
is like Dremel, but I no idea. >> Okay. Well, anyways,
I have um I see if I zoom out here a little bit now.
Um I don't know everything. This is >> a decent video today
showing Hassan noticing in chat, ignoring, stepping away, calling
the dog over, and likely removing it before acknowledging the
chats later. Uh he'd acknowledged that he'd acknowledged like
an LSF thread before Kai ever leaves the room. We get to maybe
take a look at that. I risk I risk AJW content and the viewing
of it at the cost of all viewership. Okay,
AJW content never does well in stream. You turn that guy on,
you you dip 50 to 100 viewers instantly. >> I'm about to
be Hassan and you're going to see my shock call. Whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hold on. Oh, dude. That's a running gag right there.
Yes. One of those. Okay. So, all right. What we're going to do
now,
the simplest of solutions. Okay.
This is what you would call a unobtainable item. This is
flyers. I know. wild things for everyone to own. Have you ever
seen one of these before? These devices, Mr. >> No. Never.
>> No. So, what I'm going to do is I'm going to put that
on the prong. You can see them just one ironically by solder.
Cuts the prong there. Sorry, I just >> one hand. >> Okay.
Ready? >> Yeah. That's what I assumed that you uh >> I
thought you might even need something a little bigger, but I
was like, you don't need something that most people wouldn't
have. Like, obviously, you could cut that [__] Are
you Are you me, Taylor Lauren? Okay, I'm not going to do the
other one cuz I I I think I can salvage this one, ironically,
by soldering the piece back on.
But let me let me go get some uh some hockey tape and we can
solve this mystery once and for all.
>> Journalists, by the way. >> Yeah, journalists,
by the way. Basically
>> Well, I assume you would want to file these down after
cutting them. Basically
>> One tokvert. Is this guy like caught up on the stream
or Hold on. This guy's like arguing with me in the past. He's
like losing it in a totally different place in time.
Oh, also we didn't do our >> Oh, did the links block like
something on this side? >> Let me Let me write my [__]
my phone number here. >> Okay. So, um >> what she's
going to say is that he has a fine Sharpie pen.
>> How fine? This is fine. I mean, I can I don't even You
can't write your phone number on this. You can't write your phone
number on this. >> Show the removed post. Let's see it.
>> Zoom in and show the little remove >> Went flying.
I don't know where the it >> You better find it. That's
a part of the
>> Oh, for bro. I don't know where the it >> The
people need to see it, man. This is incredibly scientific >> actually.
Is that like if I want to make this work again? Can you actually
screw this still on? Oh, there's enough left. There's enough
left. Move. It still >> you can still screw it on.
>> Oh my god. What about if he has it like this all the
time?
nothing there. >> How much adrenaline does Dan going through
his system? >> And he's like, "Listen, guys, it's all done,
right? You could still, even with that little tiny amount on,
>> you could still screw it on.
>> Dan Dan is under pressure right now. Holy sh
>> Well, you need to put Is this guy Hol.
We need to see if it still shocks." No, it still it still shocks.
It still shocks. Okay, >> zoom in on it. We We want to
see the the >> The tape. >> The cut. >> The
cut of the thing. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Oh my god. I can't believe it can still go on to that
small
>> cuz that could be hockey taped and we would never know.
>> Yeah. Well, we're about to find out. So,
>> that's the size. >> I feel like you would see
that, right?
>> I feel like you'd probably see it. We'll see what if
I'm guessing they'll um they'll put the hockey tape on the back
of it and we'll see what it looks like. >> No problem.
No problemmo. Back on there. >> No problemmo. >> No
problemmo. Okay. So, now what we're going to do, I'm not going
to, as I said, I'm not going to cut the other card. We've laid
>> Oh, I'm just going to >> We're going to try writing
Mr. Mutton's phone number here. That's what Hassan said was here.
Remember? >> That's right. >> Now, remember, there's
two things. He might say, "Uh, I didn't write it there. I put
a sticker and wrote on top of that." If that's the case, when
you ripped off the tape, the sticker would be on
>> Especially if it's a Sharpie,
>> especially. So, let's First off, this is a space pen.
This, right? >> Wait, what? >> On anything, right?
So, look,
>> that's what it is. It's special space pen. See? Boom.
I don't know why I did that. This is my stereo uh patented. >> He
doesn't realize he's cutting this >> It means that Dan
was here. I saw that on an island once when I was about five.
Taylor it off. I >> think he I think he just wants it for
a quick clip, but it doesn't matter. >> I go back. I already
clipped it out. It's there. Like this thing that basically impossible
to snap it off. Gosh, he's so like Hassan has a Boeing engineer
literally living in his house personally designing the rockets
that have gone and saved Israeli citizens. Thank you to Hassan's
brother who's who's done that. the
David's Arrow or whatever the it's called. Um like Okay, so first
off, you can't use a pen because it just write it rubs off of
this. Again, there's numbers here. So, let's see. This is a Sharpie
now. >> Uh this is So, I'm going to just try to write uh
>> try to write seven numbers. >> I'm going to just
see if I can do 1111.
one one one.
That's as small as you can get. And it's all ones. >> And
it's all ones. Get the out of here. >> Can you put the
prong back on and use the tester?
>> I know. I know it's going to work. >> I I believe
it's going to work, too. I'm just curious. >> Yeah, sure.
>> Cuz if it works, then >> Yep. Worked. You see
it? >> It's still Oh, I'm sorry. I That is a cut off prong.
>> It's not not capable of shocking. By the >> what
is being tested, um, that if Hassan cut the prongs off and left
pieces there
that we don't see through the tape, maybe you wouldn't, but I
feel like you would, that if he left the prongs there, you could
still put these additional If you left, sorry, the leads there,
you could still attach these prongs and shock something, I think,
is what we're trying to prove. >> Not capable. Impossible.
Shock, shock, shock, shock, shock. Get the [__]
>> he Well, we'll have to see what it looks like with the
tape over it. I'm guessing he's going to tape over it now. And
we'll see,
right? We'll see what it looks like with those two leads there.
Out of here.
>> Yeah, we Oh, what's up,
Trish? Sure. Uh,
yeah. One to I understand Taylor Loren said that. We watched
Taylor Lorenz's video and said that she was goofy. Um, so you're
saying that she he wrote his number there again? I have no idea
how he wrote his number there. What if he put down like masking
tape, like some other kind of tape, and then just wrote his number
on top of that?
I I don't even know. Like I don't know what we're put disproving
here that Hassan didn't write on the back of this blankly with
with Sharpie. >> Can you Wait, hold on. What happens if
you hold the ultra shock button down?
>> Oh no. >> Oh my god.
>> [__] off. No shot.
>> I noticed this happens to a lot of people. They like
actually totally lose attachment to like what proves something.
They just like they hear these guys being happy and they clap
like seals. They're like, "Oh, we did it. We did it, guys. We
won." I'm not sure that this proves anything. I thought also
the leads being like cut off would have to still produce the
shock. Like um sorry without the um the ends attached. Sean,
>> you know, I am not Dude, you know he did >> You
know he held it. You know he >> wouldn't we see the number
tape under the black tape?
>> did that debunker?
>> Look at this. Oh, it's just a second. It's just a second.
What do you call
>> Oh my god, Dan.
>> That's nuts.
>> Like it just doesn't actually map to anything. But I
understand a lot of people be very very excited about this. >> Dude,
this guy's out here killing. I'm going to say it's way worse
than it looked now. >> It is way worse than it looks >> because
he can just hold it.
>> Anyone who thinks that this is not a big deal. Okay,
I encourage you to buy this and use it on yourself. Moot, this
is fantastic because you can now use this. >> Yes, I'm
excited. >> So, there's a thing that you can buy. >> Didn't
we watch Lykan use this on himself and not react
or am I missing that?
Um, and it's a uh
it's called a um
something robot. What is it called? Uh friend. Kidding me. >> Saw
the show. He took out the recommend. But you know what? >> I
watched the same clip. >> Oh, are we going to see I want
to see Dan put the tape on now with those leads? Cuz I think
we're going to see once he cut the leads off, he shows it with
the tape, right? Do we see it with like the tape over the leads?
I think we do, right? >> Eventually here or am I missing
that? I thought he put the tape on and he showed it somewhere.
>> Please, for the love of God,
>> like and talked a lot about it, but never used it. What?
What? He never uses it. He literally has it attached to himself
right here. >> This is not a shot collar. This is an e-collar.
And then we're way too high and the voltage could be
adjusted very very incrementally. >> It could be adjusted
verbal command. They're not listening. You've given it to feel
something. Oh, he literally holds it down and you see it shocking
himself. So, Lyen is literally holding it down at the intensity
where Dan was spuring out. >> So, you've given a verbal
command. >> No, Lyan is using this exact this Why would
this be vibrate? >> They're not listening. >> Why
would Why would when the red thing goes on would that be vibrate?
>> You've given a hand gesture and they're not listening.
You've used your body language and they're not >> You literally
just used it for all of those things. Are we supposed to ignore
the fact that I watched this video? We're supposed to pretend
that this didn't happen.
>> Do is get to a point where your dog feels something.
So, you've given a verbal command. They're not listening. You've
given a hand. >> They're not listening.
>> Listen, we maybe we just got like um Listen, maybe Dan
got one that was >> How many subs for another two hours?
It looks like we're
uh nine subs. Nine subs away from another two hours on the stream,
guys. If you guys want to donate, we're nine subs away. I think
we're going to go to the JF stuff after this. Okay.
>> You've used your body language and they're not listening.
This is just >> The shock around the neck feels way different
than on the wrist. I It would definitely feel worse in the neck.
Yeah. But would it feel like a 100 times worse or I don't think
so. >> Hey, bud. Come on.
That's it. Now, why might a dog yelp when you use one of these?
If I come up and pinch you when you're sitting there and not
expecting it, you're going to go.
>> No, Lykan's not using the vi the vibrate version. Lykan
is using the shock version. Neck is way worse.
Okay, I guess we just need Lykan to put it around his neck. All
right. I I think for all of these, this is kind of funny you
say this blank, cuz I think for all of these things, actually
using it on yourself as like an ape, like a hairless ape, it's
going to be so much worse than what would get applied to the
dog as well, right? Like the dog has a thicker coat, like a a
coat of hair and skin, like a an actual hide.
Like it will be significantly worse on a human. I think
Lykan has an agenda.
Hold on. Hold on. I have to actually open up. This is going to
be really funny. Um, Lyan has an agenda. Literally 3 minutes
ago, one toker was telling me how Lykan didn't shock himself.
Lyken didn't do that. No, he didn't actually shock himself. No,
that didn't happen. He just yapped about it. And then you're
like like it has an agenda. I would just say that that's that's
funny in and of itself. It's just a little, you know, I find
it it's amusing. I like that the chatters can make me laugh,
too. I appreciate it.
Thank you, Untover. We love you, buddy. All right. What do we
have? We have really bad denims take. We have an Asmin Gold take.
I'm going to switch over to JF for I I might do JF. Maybe we'll
do it um >> on the Patreon.
Maybe we'll do Patreon
here in just a little bit. Guys, if you want to sign up for the
Patreon, that's
All right, I we'll do like a supporter tier thing. Um, I'll go
hop in there. Let me see. >> Sometime Well, like one thing
that I've learned is that whenever you whenever people on the
internet make up their mind about something,
you can't really stop that. Like, that's about it, right? Like
people are always going to think that. Even if you provide evidence
that proves the opposite, people are still going to think it.
And like he should, you know, you missed the tape part. Hold
on. Can Hold on. There's a tape part in here. Tape.
Where's the part where he tapes over it?
Would that have been before the 20?
I'm looking for where he tapes over it. Maybe this is where he
tapes over it. This looks like him putting on the leads right
here.
Yeah, I say putting the leads, but don't say Oh,
>> put that I got to get my keyboard out of the way here.
>> You're good. I even flipped it
>> Okay, so here's the size difference of the two prongs.
>> move the cam down >> around this and that's what
holds it in
And then he's like, "Listen guys, it's all done." >> End
of breakdown. Okay, I did want to see that. So, >> we cut
it off. >> We got a piece of tape here. >> That's
as small as
Okay, we're looking for where that tape >> Stale 2000.
Hello. My >> I saw
>> fake ass excuse
>> thing that's ever happened. What do you want me to do?
>> Is that you are so part of what's >> on to that
and be like address I'll send >> somehow it entirely tape.
I don't know what's going on that I'm missing it >> Special
space about if he has it like this all the time. Okay. Whenever
you're bad on stream hockey tape dog.
Okay.
Oh, yeah. But you can clearly see this is this is before they're
cut off, right? You can clearly see them through the tape, right?
You can clearly see where the leads are through the tape. They're
poking through. Like you've got like fully erect nipples, right?
Like that's what we would have expected with the other tape.
And that's what we'd expect here. And it is still poking through.
Yeah. Okay. >> And then this is probably a little bit shiny.
Like this is probably maybe worn down because the poor doggo
has been shocked so many times. Hold on.
>> Oh yeah. Oh, hold on. Give me Give me one second. Hold
on. Stand by. >> Ladies and gentlemen,
we got him.
>> Per shot
in the >> Oh my god. It was just one second. >> So
the the prongs definitely would have to be taken off. I think
he he gets rid of the prongs after this, right? Like after this
where he goes and grabs the pliers and gets rid of them. That's
not the cut off prong, is it?
Or is that the cut off prong? 47, I thought, was where he starts
doing this. Okay, it's got to be after Sasha where he goes and
cuts it off, right? He only cuts one. Is that the cut off one?
>> Wear and tear. What has happened? And oh my god, it's
almost like these things that can't be hidden. Look, you can't
even see the
>> You can't see the other prong. >> You can't see
it. You if I just move it around, you can't see it, guys. You
can't see it at all. >> Of wear and tear, >> guys.
You can't You can't see it. You just can't you can't even see
it a little bit. You can't even you can't see it at all. >> Happens
and Oh my god. It's almost like these things that >> you
could clearly see it the entire time. He's trying to get it over
in the shade as he like shakes. He keeps showing it accidentally.
>> Look, you can't even see the
>> You look You can't even see the prong, guys. You can't
even see this clear nipple sticking out through the tape at all,
guys. You can't You can't see through it. Okay, you can't you
can't see it. If I just keep saying that you can't see it, eventually
you won't be able to see it, guys. You just you can't you you
can't see it at all. It's like,
wait, Smatic, that would be super funny. Uh, if we went to that
Airite clip from the other day when we're like going back and
forth with the frames and just get Dan, okay, get Dan's hands
going over that that scene. You can't see it. Look, you can't
see it. You can't see it at all. You can't see it at all. >> Can't
even see it. >> You can't You can't even see it. Mood agrees.
You can't even see it, guys. It's like not even there. If I just
keep saying it, you'll eventually remember. Uh, you'll eventually
remember that you can't see it. Actually, just I'm telling you
that you can't see it. Okay? So, just keep in mind that you can't
see this thing that's clearly protruding
God, I
honestly,
you want to know what the worst part of streaming is?
It's realizing that like you think you're doing something. you
think you're like um you think you're like entertaining or you
think you're like doing something and it's not you're not doing
what you think you're doing, right? Like there are so many people
who could watch this and they'll go, "Yeah, you can't see it
through the tape actually at all, guys. You can't see can't see
anything going on there. >> Yo, Division 5 player, thank
the 10 gifties over on kick. What's up?" Or sorry, over on Twitch
it looks like. Thank you for the 10 gifties.
We had those. Listen, I appreciate it. We'll throw the two hours
up. I totally I totally forgotten
about that. I thought forgot I was chilling and for the stream.
Thank you so much, Division Five player. Appreciate it, buddy.
Yeah. Um anyway, worst part about streaming is you think people
like care about, you know, your opinion or the truth or something.
They actually just don't. They just want you to like reiterate
the thing they want to hear. That's it every single time. It's
very goofy. Uh, I I guarantee if I go to this chat, I'll see
a whole bunch of people who are like in here who like um who
who just want to be told this exact thing who are probably in
my chat often. Okay, I see literally like four people right off
the bat. Like four people who I can tell are in my chat would
be in my chat and they just don't they just keep going. It's
fine. Just keep
just just like clapping. They're clapping. They're clapping.
>> You can't see the other prong. And I can still attach
>> Can't see the other. You can still attach the tip. >> You
can still attach the tip. Look at
>> Look. Look at that. Look at that, guys. You can clearly
see it. If I get it out of focus, if I like don't tilt it too
much. Oh, no. Dan, we're seeing it again. Dan, we're seeing it.
Tilted. >> Who is the debun?
>> It's debunked, guys. It's debunked.
If you tell me you see a n a nipple there, you are lying to me.
Okay? If you tell me there's a nipple there, you are lying. You
are full of it. You are lying to me. I can't see it. You actually
can't see it. You can't see this clear nipple sticking out.
Are we pretending? >> Bunker now. You can't see the other
prong. And I can still attach. >> You can still attach
it right here. Oh, hold on.
>> You can't see this thing clearly sticking out right
here. >> You can't see this thing clearly sticking out
right here.
>> You can't see this thing clearly sticking out right
here. >> Attach the tip. >> Can't see it clearly
protruding. >> Look at that.
You can't see it clearly protruding here. At what point can you
not see it here? Cuz I can literally see it the whole time as
it moves around this screen. >> Where is the debunk? >> I
I can't, guys. I can't see. Where is it? I just don't see it
at all.
>> I I just don't see it. I just can't I can't, man. This
is It's just very funny. Very very very funny.
>> Now, XQC, >> sorry, XQC. There's a new debunker.
>> All right. Now I we're going to try two things. First
thing is I happen to have the finest of tips. I have a >> Okay.
All right. Well Well, I don't know what else do we do there.
Did I look away and you got to 10 subs? Uh you Yeah, I might
have. I did. We got Division five player over in the Twitch
true. It doesn't look like anything to me, guys. Okay, this is
Listen, I don't see anything. There's nothing there. There's
nothing there. I mean, we all know you can cut it and have it
be hidden.
Sorry. The argument was you could cut it and have it be hidden
and still shock the dog with it, right?
Or if we're just arguing that you could cut it and you could
get rid of them entirely, then we all agreed with that, right?
I'm just pointing out that clearly with the way Dan's doing it,
you could still see the thing and then he goes, "You can't see,
you can't even see it like this and you could still shock the
dog." That's just not true. All of that is, by the way, totally
like a It's like what do you call it? It's like a total mislead.
Anyway, because even if even if that were true, like they would
still say Hassan probably cut them off after. Like it literally
doesn't matter. Yeah. Just total red herring. Exactly.